bonjour a bien sonné pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui géré
l'accueil jérémy descous cardiologue et
à hauteur de la chaîne assez les pièces
j'ai pas dis des bêtises asklepios mais
c'est pas loin c'est pas loin et c'est
le pire c'est quoi et donc est ce que tu
pourrais commencer par te présenter pour
un thé un peu ton parcours maintenant on
parcourra c'est à dire sur le plan
médical tu veux dire ouais le scolaire
professionnel des garrigots suppression
au niveau scolaire professionnel ben
c'est un peu un peu bas c'est assez
simple en fait le parcours que j'ai eu
sur le plan scolaire but faire bac s
j'ai je suis rentré à la faculté un
petit peu par dépit à la base je voulais
faire j'ambitionnais plutôt de partir
sur une filière un peu kiné j'ai pas eu
entre guillemets les accès parce qu'à
une époque il y avait beaucoup des
concours très sélectif à l'époque donc
je vais voulu partir sur de la kiné en
belgique et en gros ils m'ont dit non
ils m'ont dit qu'ils étaient pas
possible parce que je m'étais pris
beaucoup trop de retard et j'ai fait une
année de médecine entre lee mais pour me
familiariser un petit peu avec anatomy
et tout ça et j'en suis jamais repartie
en fait donc j'ai eu un parcours somme
toute assez classique je suis sortie du
bac à pour faire la faculté de médecine
que j'ai eu à jules ma première année en
doublant c'est à dire je vais redoubler
la première qui est un petit peu occupé
à côté et puis ensuite je fais un
parcours classique l'internât j'ai fini
car dieu femme âgée fait mon internat
cardio sur quatre ans j'ai passé
quelques d une notamment
d'échocardiographie de rythmologie de
stimulation cardiaque
j'ai un master 2 en nutrition humaine et
santé aussi que j'ai passés pendant ma
scolarité parce que je me suis dit que
je m'embêtais un peu non voyants et et
puis voilà j'ai fait deux années de
formation en rythmologie en partant de
l'internât mais maintenant je suis en
train de s'installer en libéral
donc ça c'est pour le parcours
professionnel après sur le parcours en
vulgarisation c'est quand j'ai fini mon
internat j'avais passé ma thèse à
regarder des youtube heures en fait
expliqué des trucs sur internet je
trouvais ça super cool
à l'époque c'était notamment y penser
qu'il y avait un qui tenait la corde il
y avait notament aînés qui sortait donc
je me suis dit ah ouais quand j'aurai
terminé je me lancerai peut-être sur le
créneau en médecine parce qu'il ait pas
grand chose des primum non nocere et qui
était inquiété sur un lien sur le
créneau mais il était tout seul et je me
suis dit que j'allais gens c'est ma
chaîne sur cette base là l'idée c'était
un petit peu de faire de l'épistémologie
de faire de l'histoire des sciences au
travers d'histoires de la médecine et
d'intégrer à des notions en prime et
d'histoire des sciences de compréhension
de la méthode scientifique au travers de
l'histoire de la médecine donc c'est un
petit peu le projet à la base et puis
c'est ça qui m'a amené à ouvrir la
chaîne à prendre un tour un petit peu je
vais pas dire décalé parce que tout le
monde un ton décalé mais un ton un petit
peu plus frais pour essayer de parler de
médecine ou de sujets un petit peu grave
donc voilà ok donc des buts a voulu
devenir jsk qui était la motivation pour
aller plusieurs métiers et ya un truc
qui m'a intéressé ma motivation pour
aller vers la médecine
ben je sais pas trop en fait je voulais
avoir un métier à la fois sur lequel il
y ait des qualités humaines qui soit
requis c'est à dire où il ya un vrai
sens du métier ont fait ce truc pour de
bonnes raisons il ya un véritable
objectif
il ya un vrai truc quelque chose qui
soit à la fois technique c'est-à-dire
houllier un savoir technique une
compréhension une méthodologie
particulière donc quelque chose qui soit
on qu'on puisse pratiquer c'est à dire
qu'il ya une vérité une véritable
application pratique et en même temps un
seuil de connaissances théoriques qui
soit important c'est à dire qu'il
fallait connaître des trucs mais il faut
pas seulement connaître des trucs il
faut les mettre en application les
appliquer au réel c'était quelque chose
qui me paraissait important à ce moment
là et puis jamais été un très grand
manuel c'est pour ça que j'ai fait dix
ans d'études ne suivent pas ce que dira
donc donc l'idée c'est un petit peu ça
et c'était de partir sur comment te dire
sur sur quelque chose qui soit très
concret c'est à dire qui des
applications concrètes pratiques mais
sur lequel il est un niveau d'évolution
scientifique et où on met à jour ses
connaissances en permanence c'est
quelque chose qui me paraissait
intéressant mais c'est quelque chose que
j'ai pas découvert mais en sortant du
bac quoi c'est vraiment j'ai commencé à
faire mes études que j'ai commencé à
comprendre la matière que là j'ai trouvé
que c'était intéressant et que c'était
cet aspect à la fois technique et
scientifique qui était à qui était
important pour moi
du côté un peu stimulant
intellectuellement il faut que ce soit
stimulant intellectuellement c'est à
dire il faut que je découvre des choses
et puis il faut surtout que mes
croyances soient remises en cause en
permanence c'est à dire que je peux pas
me satisfaire de apprendre un truc est
de me dire voilà c'est comme ça c'est
statique ça bougera jamais non je me dis
qu'il ya toujours quelque chose à
découvrir même en anatomie même en
physiologie même sur des trucs qui sont
entre guillemets qu'on a l'impression
que c'est immuable c'est à dire que les
os du crâne il ya toujours temps 2 du
crâne mais on aura toujours plus à
apprendre sur à quoi ils servent
comment il fonctionne quelles sont leurs
marques caractéristiques propres et il
ya des tas de trucs qu'on continue de
découvrir en anatomie humaine qu'on
découvre en physiologie qu'on découvre
sur le fonctionnement cellulaire
c'est quelque chose qui est en mouvance
particulière pas particulièrement parce
que elle est souvent changé ou évolué ou
se transforment et non parce que
l'éclairage qu'on va donner sur les
différentes matières qu'on va avoir
nous apporte des données supplémentaires
qui suggère toujours plus de questions
moi c'est ça qui me fascine en fait
c'est à dire qu'il ya toujours plus de
questions toujours des éléments de
compréhension et à chaque fois qu'on
découvre un truc de nouveau ça suscite
dix fois plus d'interrogations et c'est
en ça que je pense qu'on est sur une
matière même si elle a l'air assez fini
pour habitude de du corps humain ou de
la médecine humaine ses seins à l'air
d'être fin et définitif mais il ya
toujours des trucs à découvrir et notre
compréhension du corps humain je pense
qu'elle en est encore aux balbutiements
le corps humain est suffisamment
complexe pour pour nous occuper pendant
ouais je pense oui je pense qu'on en a
encore pour quelques siècles quelques
millénaires donc et tu regardes pas du
goût du vin parce que tu voudras pas
devenu qui ne regrette pas du tout ça
d'être devenu kiné bah non en fait parce
que j'étais un peu une idée comme ça
c'est à dire que à la fin de votre bac 1
d'ailleurs s'il ya des jeunes qui
m'écoutent à la fin de ma terminale je
savais pas du tout ce que je voulais
faire j'ai mes parents qui me tannait
qu'il me demandait faut faire un truc
parce que dans la vie il faut faire des
trucs et moi j'étais à jeudi mais je
sais pas je suis tombé je sais pas sûr
sur des sites internet à l'époque ça
commençait un peu juste en 2004 je
dirais et avait dû site internet qui
parlait de fines et donc j'ai dû bien
qu'une et voilà pour repasser à l'air
d'être moindres vient d'apprendre madiba
kiné non et puis j'ai dit bon bain
médecine alors et mes fils je suis allé
sur internet et j'ai trouvé que c'était
cool qui avaient des interactions mais
il y avait des trucs qui se disaient
c'était incompréhensible pour moi il y
avait des gens ils disent oui oui alors
pour médecine il faut travailler 10
heures par jours week-end compris les
vacances aussi tout ça et j'ai dit vous
êtes vous êtes louf les gars jamais
j'arriverai à bout ces dix heures par
jour déjà je bosse 1h30 dans la journée
je suis au bout de ma vie donc c'est
quelque chose qui était complètement
inconcevable pour moi même après
maintenant c'est devenu mon quotidien
mais à l'époque à bosser des sounders
comme ça 2 par moi même parce que ces
systèmes faquins on n'est pas du tout
driver c'est à dire qu'il fallait que je
m'installe devant mon bouquin et de moi
même il fallait que je me force à
regarder le truc pendant 10 heures à
leur passé leur revoir revoir à 1000
fois de faire mille qcm dessus jusqu à
le maîtriser totalement et ça c'était
aulas était c'est pas du tout concevable
pour mon mois de 17 en quoi c'était pas
possible mais pourtant parfois houleux
ça colle conseils que tu donneras à des
jeunes qui sont dit qu'ils sont en train
de songer à l'ordre filières post-bac
hub sur leurs filières post bac
je dirais que tous les profils sont
acceptables sur la faculté al'avantage
que j'avais de l'université est en train
d'évoluer avec avec post-bac là avec la
nouvelle réforme post bac en france là
mais c'est que tous les profils sont
acceptables c'est à dire vous n'êtes pas
prédestiné ses parts à 17 ans emma parce
que 17 ans et parce que vous voulez
faire
vous êtes nuls mais par contre quand
vous lancez dans un truc il faut vous
lancer à fond faut vous donner le
maximum de chances qu'ils soient
possibles
après les autres filières moi je les
connais pas tant que ça je sais pas trop
comment ça se passe je suis sur une spé
qui est extrêmement dirigiste c'est à
dire que tu rentres en médecine tu finis
en médecine à la fin des médecins et ses
morts enfin il n'y a pas d'autres
possibilités dû réfléchir différemment
quoi donc moi je suis j'étais sur un peu
sur des rails
si tu veux donc à la fin j'avais mon
métier j'avais ma spécialité parce que
j'ai passé les examens parce que j'ai eu
les concours qu'ils allaient bien mais
concrètement il n'y avait pas moyen
d'être extrêmement original sur le
parcours tu pouvais faire quelques
diplômes universitaires par ci par là
pour entre guillemets est au fait un
petit peu tout ça mais concrètement le
basique c'est le parcours fac tel qu'il
est et qu'il est prédestiné moi ce que
je dirai aux jeunes c'est que sur la
première année de médecine en tout cas
c'est qu'elle vous prépare
contrairement à ce que vous pouvez
imaginer vous préparent assez bien c'est
à dire que on se dit mais que ça sera
pas d'apprendre que moi je me rappelle
de ce que je disais à ma mère à l'époque
ça sert à quoi d'apprendre l'anatomie de
la drosophile j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de
la drosophile à ça ne m'intéresse pas de
savoir les interactions vieux
cellulaires entre des cellules de cochon
ou quoi ou de savoir que pv légal nrt
certaines règles de mécanique quantique
dont jour est quasiment rien à [ __ ]
par la suite c'est vrai on s'en fiche
mais c'est pas ça qu'on vous demande en
première année est ce qu'on vous demande
en première année c'est une force de
travail c'est-à-dire une capacité
d'abnégation c'est à dire de pouvoir
bosser une quantité suffisante et de
faire ce qu'on vous demande c'est à dire
une certaine loi d'obéissance de
compréhension de la consigne est là on
forme des internes c'est à dire des gens
qui sont capables de rester éveillé
pendant 24 heures et de rester
performant
quel que soit le niveau de fatigue quel
que soit le niveau d'exigence qu'on peut
avoir envers eux et c'est en ça que sa
forme bien c'est à dire que sa seleccion
un certain profil de population et ça
évite que il est trop de gens qui
craquent par la suite parce que c'est
vraiment ça on est vraiment extrêmement
exigeants extrêmement dur
avec nous parce que mr on vit des
moments qui sont dures une exigence de
quantité de travail est de qualité de
travail qui doit être maintenue malgré
un degré de fatigue malgré un degré de
dents maire de meaux maximale et il faut
rester que ce soit en pleine journée ou
à 4 heures du matin il faut avoir
toujours le même la même réflexion
le même cheminement de diagnostic pour
que les patients ont primé mais s'en
sortent quoi et c'est à ça que ça nous
forment en fait même si on s'en fout de
l'anatomie de la drosophile
même si vous avez probablement l'oublier
des six mois qui vont suivre après ça
vous apprendra vous posez et lutter
contre le sommeil à être résistant et à
être machin c'est en ça que sa forme
bien après ça pourrait former un peu
mieux sur certaines qualités humaines
mais ça en corse et c'est discutable est
ce qu on attend vraiment de médecins
qu'ils soient gentils j'en suis pas sûr
moi j'attends surtout d'un médecin qui
soit empathique et qu'il ait les
capacités de recueillir l'information et
de pouvoir traiter l'information pour
traiter le patient le mieux possible
le fait qu'ils soient gentils agréable
tout ça sahara est à mon avis un petit
accessoire se sent pas mais c'est pas ce
qu'on lui demande
la base qu'on demande aux médecins c'est
qu'ils parlent qu'ils fassent le bon
diagnostic et qui propose le monde
traitement et que la prise en charge sur
la meilleure possible d'après vous peut
se disputer après là dessus mais
effectivement je pense que l'éthique
c'est surtout de d'être performant et de
pouvoir donner les meilleurs soins
possibles au moment t au patient et je
crois que c'est une des bases sur
lesquelles je me fonde pour essayer de
bosser deux patrons faire de conneries
en fait assez rare quand même vachement
exigeante été les moments où il opère de
motivation oui oui bien sûr pas tous
ceux qui vous disent que non ils n'ont
jamais perdu la motivation et qu'ils
étaient comme d'henri iv annonce
vraiment évidemment c'est fait pour
qu'on doute c'est fait pour que ce soit
difficile c'est fait pour être exigeant
ça fait chier de bosser 10h machin ça
fait chier de passer ses week-ends à ses
vacances de noël à à bosser sur des
courts complètement absconse est vrai
que c'est nul
mais au final je sais pas ça vous donne
une capacité de dépassement tout ça
c'est aussi un défi c'est un peu la même
logique que les maîtres qui font du
trail et qui pendant huit heures vont
aller courir ne répond pas à se faire du
mal et à la fin ils tenir une
satisfaction il ya un peu de ça il ya un
peu de ça et il ya surtout quand même
c'est cool à la fin c'est à dire qu'on
apprend des tas de trucs on a un niveau
de compréhension qu'il était génial quoi
donc on découvre on découvre énormément
de choses ont donc non des études de
médecine
elles sont vachement cool elles sont
super dur il ya plein de problèmes on
pourrait relever sur les études de
médecine sur comment elles sont faites
et comment on pourrait les améliorer
mais en soi ça reste sans cesse des bons
moments quand même de vous voir un peu
ça comme comme un défi et puis c'est
d'imaginer ce que ça serait que d'avoir
relevé ce défi ce conseil c'est surtout
de se dire qu'il faut donner tout ce
qu'on a pour a pour y arriver que c'est
pas facile je sais pas accessible à tout
le monde ne faut pas se mentir c'est un
concours sélectif et que si on veut s'en
sortir il faut pas partir avec avec des
a priori moi tout le monde m'avait dit
faut prendre une prépa privée pour le
faire bon j'ai pas pris de prépa privée
ça s'est bien passé
tout le monde m'a dit il faut faire il
faut faire comme ça il faut faire une
préparation particulière il faut sortir
de tel lycée tel truc tel machin
bon voila apres c il ya aussi un billet
du survivant moi c'est à dire que moi
j'ai réussi les études de médecine ne
t'a pas tous les discours de ceux qui
les ont ratés mais moi j'ai fini à jeter
à la fin j'étais 4e de promo j'avais pas
de prépa machin et j'avais tout fait par
moi même dans mes selles d'études
je me souviens que j'étais à l'époque
j'étais acheté mon pays j'étais dans une
cité qui s'appelait la voie domitienne
c'était des petites chambres est de 9 m²
tu touchais les mûriers pas de frigo il
y avait que dalle et c'est dans ces
conditions là que je les ai pas si je me
suis à même il y avait un mais voisin
qui m'a piqué mon frigo
alors que j'étais là quoiqu'il rentrée
qui maquille m'appliquer un truc qui
avait dans mon frigo qui s'est cassé
c'était un peu des conditions dégradées
c'est quand même plus sympa quand il ya
des gens avec toi quand tu as maison est
grande et tout ça mais moi ça m'a permis
de pas avoir tout un tas de distraction
typiquement moi je suis un gros fan de
jeux vidéo et j'ai eu à l'époque une ps2
ou une ps3 danse et une baisse de à
l'époque ainsi ma chère tu es une ps2
dans la chambre c'était mort j'avais un
ordinateur j'avais une sorte de cyber
café pour y songer à dans une
boulangerie à côté avec tu sais les un
clavier avec des touches en plastique
pour pas qu'ils s'abîment en fait donc
c'est en plastique mou et là dessus
jallet sur internet une heure une heure
et demie ça me coûte un bras c'était une
autre époque mais si c'est pour qu'on
dit conditions dégradées à ça j'ai même
pas si ça existe toujours les cybercafés
je crois pas ouais c'était déjà en
matant l'acadie au web non mais c'est
vrai qu'à la télé le téléphone avec avec
la 4g ce titre notre époque on était en
effet loin de ça fait un master en
nutrition c'est en fait en fait si chez
nous en fait tu fais d un master 1 et
master 2 ça donne une qualification pour
rentrer sur un cursus universitaire pour
devenir chef de clinique
c'est le stade au dessus de long terme
c'est à dire quand tu continues était
une balance universitaire que tu donne
quelques cours que tu participes à une
activité de recherche
tu peux être chef de clinique mais une
exigence maintenant parce qu'il ya de
plus en plus d'un terne il ya deux mois
des postes de chef de clinique de moins
en moins nombreux parce que c'est bien
connu on manque de médecins mais on
recrute de moins en moins de médecins
donc voilà donc les postes de chef de
clinique c'est hyper rare et pour
pouvoir challenge et pour pouvoir
essayer d'avoir un poste de chef de
clinique il fallait avoir un master 2
donc moi je vais passer à un master 2 de
nutrition humaine et santé non à la
maison quand j'ai appris pas mal de
trucs ça restait prêt à prêter aux
ricains c'était de la bio celle de la
biologie du likoud de la biologie
moléculaire
des trucs un petit peu ce pays j'avais
fait des stats mon dieu c'était des
biostate à un niveau j'ai rien j'ai rien
compris mais vraiment j'ai rien compris
et c'est là que je me suis rendu compte
que mes études de médecine était quand
même très bourrine parce que j'ai rien
compris les biostate inspire je suis
incapable de dire maintenant ce que j'ai
lu sur le truc je sais juste que j'ai
restituer exactement ce qu'ils avaient
marqué dans le truc sans rien y
comprendre sans rien en savoir
je les restituer tel quel sur ma copie
et c'est ma meilleure note du masters en
fait je crois que j'ai eu 16 ou 17 ouais
voilà c'est je pense que c'est pas
possible entre guillemets pour quelqu'un
qui a fait le master 2 va faire avec les
jeunes qui étaient en master 2 com -
mais non enfin en médecine à un niveau
d'exigence qui est tellement fort et
cette espèce de bourrinage un thé qui
est intégré complètement à notre manière
de penser qui fait que bassam était
beaucoup plus accessible qu'à quelques
mois qu'ils abordent sans avoir fait
médecine avant donc que je me dis je
c'est à ce moment là où je me suis dit
on est quand même les gros bourrins mais
voilà après j'ai pas de voilà je ne
serai pas peut-être expliquer ni comment
ni pourquoi c'est juste que voilà c'est
ma meilleure note malgré tout alors que
vraiment j'y crois je comprenais rien il
y avait des histoires de boîtes de
machin il y avait des séquences à
apprendre par coeur pour enfin c'était
d'une complexité rare et on m'a dit
qu'il fallait avoir les trois aînés de
stats avant malheureusement je les avais
pas j'ai attrapé le cursus en master 1
et du coup ça me manquait un peu quoi
ouais je pense qu'il y avait
suffisamment de liens entre la médecine
de lien on prend les médecines la
recherche oui parce que les médecins
sont des acteurs de terrain c'est à dire
que ce sont eux qui collecte les données
ce sont eux qui participent au protocole
ce sont eux
un mec qui sont en contact avec les
patients qui savent collecter la donne
et c'est quand même pas facile pour un
patient de savoir si les compliants de
savoir quel est son traitement de savoir
quelle est sa compréhension du
traitement dont je pense qu'on est
impliqué dans la recherche
après je pense qu'on devrait plus
participer aux travaux de recherche que
la plupart des travaux de recherche
devraient être publiés c'est à dire que
même les travaux négatif même les
travaux qui sont entre guillemets un peu
bof
tout ça devrait être publiée d'une
manière ou d'une autre et je pense que
la recherche de manière générale devrait
peu plus accessible en fait on a un
système de recharge j'imagine que c'est
pareil chez tournant matin mais l'accès
aux travaux de recherche la diffusion de
la connaissance en fait c'est quelque
chose qui devient compliqué qu'on est
obligé de de transgresser on utilise en
prix mais quand on est universitaire on
peut utiliser la faculté pour accéder à
une grande revue tout ça quand on est
sorti du système qu'on est libéral quand
mois là soit il faut prendre des
abonnements qui coûtera et demi et
auquel cas berre la plupart ne le font
pas soit on est obligé de passer par des
systèmes pirates
d'ailleurs je vous déconseille d'aller
sur sa gueule parce que c'est totalement
illégal est interdite mais c'est une des
manières de diffuser à de diffuser
l'information scientifique mais il faut
pas y aller mais c'est quand même très
très bien mais il faut pas du tout via
les mathématiques en informatique et en
physique la plupart des gens en fait
mettre en ligne sur un site s'appelle
arxiv où tout est dit disponible et
après ils soumettent à des journaux qui
peuvent en être payant mais du coup en
fin d année les articles sont seconds
nous c'est un petit peu compliqué parce
que tu veux sur la recherche
ton article toi tu le sou mais j'ai pas
s'il faut faire un topo sur la recherche
commun les fêtes en médecine en gros tu
soumettons article c'est à dire tu as
étudié des patients tu dis c'est cool
et tu le soumet à des revues tu dire tu
dis at-elle revue je vais soumettre at
elle en lui parce que mon travail est de
qualité quand même assez bonne donc je
peux espérer une revue qui est assez
bonne et en fait les chercheurs sont
rémunérés ou les services sont
récompensés d'une manière ou d'une autre
en fonction de la hype que suggère la
revue dans laquelle ils vont publier une
revue super cool comme nature ou comme
un sayan sous comme je ne sais pas le
ljm chez nous qui est le new england
journal of medecine cd revues
prestigieuses et du coup elles ont un
fort ce qu'on appelle un facteur
d'impact un impact factor qui est
excellent et du coup il faut publier
dans ces revues cd revues qui sont à
comité de lecture c'est à dire qu'il ya
des mecs
mes médecins qui sont experts qui vont
gratuitement regardez le papier vérifier
que son plan méthodologique ça colle qui
manquerait 1 de bons et qu'ils vont dire
à la revue c'est ok c'est un bon papier
on peut le publier donc c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionne
le véritable problème c'est que toi tu
soumet pas revu donc des fois même tu
payes pour que par vue soient publics
alors que c'est disponible sur internet
avant c'est ce qu'on appelait les frais
de publication c'est à dire il fallait
un bel mais il ya un peu le papelard
qu'ils allaient être diffusées tous à la
revue papier maintenant c'est un petit
peu suranné je crois que ça soit encore
dans quelques bévues mais la plupart
sont largement informatisé et les mecs
qui font la review sont pas payés ou
très peu en fait
et en gros les mecs en groupe pas tu
payes pour être publié et les mecs
vendre ton article pour qu'il soit vu
par d'autres genre de mec qui paye pour
pouvoir faire d'autres articles et au
final c'est toujours le même mec qui
reçoit l'argent et mais c'est l'éditeur
parce que nous concrètement on reçoit
pas l'argent de la publication de ce
truc qui ajuste une feuille la notoriété
du chercheur qui va être augmentée mais
concrètement en termes de financement ça
permet aussi de justifier quelques
financements de dire voilà on est en
gros centres de recherche à l'état donc
monsieur l'état donnez-moi plus d'argent
mais concrètement l'éditeur c'est pas
lui qui va vous redistribuez l'argent
qu'il a reçus des gens qui ont acheté
votre article ça c'est ça marche pas
comme ça donc on est dans un système
entre guillemets ou les éditeurs
scientifiques ont moins en moins de
frais gagne de plus en plus de thunes et
où la diffusion du savoir et de plus en
plus compliqué parce que ça coûte 2
en plus cher d'ailleurs à chaque fois si
vous voulez dire mon article je veux
qu'il soit disponible à tout le monde
c'est à dire qu'ils soient diffusés et
qu'il soit en accès libre
voilà vous devez payer un sus une payé
2000 balles en plus pour que votre
article soit en accès libre et ça
évidemment comme le chercheur va pas le
payer de sa poche parce que déconner non
plus ni le médecin ni le chercheur malka
et comme les universités ben non non non
plus avons pas le payer de sa poche mais
ça se fait très rarement donc l'open
access c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez difficile à mettre en place en
médecine en écriture c'est compliqué
mais ça à mon avis et c'est l'avenir
c'est de toute façon un chercheur il
fait tout pour que son article soit vu
par le maximum de monde et les éditeurs
scientifiques aujourd'hui sont pas des
entre guillemets des acteurs de la
diffusion des savoirs et sont plutôt en
prime et des freins à mon sens mais il
n'y a pas de système alternatif qui
existe véritablement il n'y a pas de
considération au niveau de l'état des
travaux en open source donc on n'a aucun
intérêt entre guillemets à valoriser ce
genre de truc dont tant qu'on n'aura pas
réformer notre manière de voir la
science de finances des vingt six ans en
france on sera toujours soumis aux mêmes
freins et c'est quelque chose qui
devient compliqué mais pour te répondre
parce que je digresse amor répondre
ouais le médecin à mon avis doit avoir
une influence en recherche parce qu'il à
cet aspect pratique qui est important il
ya des médecins qui sont très impliqués
sur plan théorique 1 c'est ce que font
les professeurs universitaires qui sont
plus impliqués là-dedans mais je pense
qu'il ya une interdépendance entre les
chercheurs en prime et théorique entre
les gens qui font d'eux il faut qu'il y
ait une interaction forte entre ceux qui
font de la médecine et ceux qui font de
la médecine
enfin du fondamental des chutes des
choses qui sont moins appliqués pour que
l'on puisse un petit peu développée à ce
niveau là mais ouais je pense que le
médecin ça peut être un bon acteur de
terrain ça peut être un bon acteur de
recherche mais il faut utiliser ses
compétences et il faut valoriser les
compétences des autres chercheurs qui
sont à côté et qui a des fois ce sont un
peu dévalorisés vis-à-vis de tout ça
parce que vous
je pense que docteur en biologie
cellulaire il a tout autant sa place en
recherche car comme médecin avec une
petite valence en biologie cellulaire
c'est juste donc juste pour ceux qui
n'ont jamais entendu parler de ces
problèmes de publication il ya une super
vidéo d'ortie biologie qui sorti
récemment je commence à peine mais qui
parle d'un truc sur la mafia
scientifique mais c'est un peu ça un peu
les éditeurs à ce que le système qui
s'auto entretient et qui en fait dans le
passé a peut-être été en effet un
médiateur qui permettait de cordelia
recherche aujourd'hui qui semble eu vent
de la vie de tous les chercheurs que je
connais en tout cas qui sont que
vraiment beaucoup plus un frein à la
diffusion de la connaissance que c'est
scandaleux avant l'éditeur scientifique
y publier une revue il a distribué c'est
à dire que lee données entre guillemets
accès à ces revues faut se rendre compte
du moment où il n'y avait pas internet
et où vous deviez entre guillemets
récupérer les revues en mode papier
maintenant qu'il ya internet que les
trucs sont accessibles voilà c'est juste
il vous suffit d'avoir le code d'accès
pour avoir machin donc en termes de
frais de publication ça reste quand même
minime quoi et voilà et sai hub permet
d'avoir accès à ce genre de contenu pour
la plupart n'ont pas tous mais pour la
plupart d'avoir accès à tous ces
contenus gratuitement
donc c'est tout à fait illégal parce que
savard langue comme dell se virent mais
concrètement c'est ce qui nous permet en
libéral d'accéder ce qu'on va pas se
mentir vas pas payer 170 vols pour
accéder à une revue quoi ça paraît
complètement con c'est super cher c'est
pas accessible par quelqu'un d'autre que
les institutionnels les universitaires
le cern l'inserm tout saf cia que eux
qui ont accès à ça et nous entre
l'immeuble quand on est hors du système
universitaire convertir la connaissance
il n'y a pas de choix quoi en faire
autrement ça on peut bâtir notre sujet
du coup maintenant pourquoi sont un peu
ton quotidien dans le ligue arabe
dans le libéral excellente question bien
actuellement je suis en train de prendre
une succession je suis en train de
prendre une succession donc je suis en
train de récupérer la patientèle d'un
collègue qui part à la retraite
c'est assez sympa donc je suis en train
d'organiser machin mais en fait mes
journées elles ont elles se ressemblent
jamais trop c'est à dire que j'ai des
jets des créneaux entre guillemets j'ai
les demi journées par exemple de
consultation je vois des gens qui
viennent pour différents problèmes des
fois de par eux mêmes en dés fois
adressé par un médecin généraliste et je
fais un bilan cardiologique je regarde
un petit peu ce qu'ils ont je
sélectionne les examens qui barrent est
le plus adapté à leur est alors état
pour essayer de répondre à leurs
questions s'ils en ont une et je fais en
sorte de pouvoir répondre à leurs
questions des fois c'est les
consultations de suivi c'est à dire ses
patients mais qui ont une pathologie
cardiaque ont des maladies maladie des
coronaires est une maladie sur une valve
tout ça où je regarde je suis tout ça je
suis la réparation des fois c'est à dire
que on a réparé une coroner on a changé
la valve et je regarde que tout
fonctionne bien et que ça se passe
toujours très bien des fois c'est des
gens qui ont des palpitations qu'on est
trouble du rythme c'est à dire un
nouveau problème et j'essaie de savoir
ce qu'il en est la plupart des gens bien
soit il ya un problème réel et on essaie
de le traiter soit entre guillemets
c'est du ressenti c'est à dire que les
gens ressentent une douleur mais qui
correspond pas grand chose sur le plan
cardiaque
on ressemble des palpitations mais en
fait lorsque vous regardez ce qui se
passe à ce moment là et se passe pas
grand chose et on a quand même une
population de patients qui sont un peu
anxieux quand même c'est à dire qu'on a
beaucoup beaucoup de gens chez qui on
élimine le diagnostic cardiologique pour
se concentrer sur la prise en charge de
l'anxiété c'est quelque chose qui est en
train de monter c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'on voit c'est à dire que et on
fait des des échographies cardiaques
anxiolytiques de gens qui sont stressés
d'avoir le coeur qui va s'arrêter ou
ou deux trucs comme ça et au final voilà
on a un petit peu de ça après j'ai aussi
des créneaux des preuves d'efforts c'est
à dire que j'évalue la compétence à
l'effort des patients ou je regarde si l
effort les artères coronaires vont bien
donc j'ai aussi sage et des créneaux
pour des examens un peu plus spécifique
d'échographie dobutamine qui sont des
tests à l'effort un petit peu comme ça à
un moment donné j'avais des créneaux
pour implanter des pacemakers des
défibrillateurs je les ai plus parce que
c'était chronophage que c'était un petit
peu compliqué sur le plan de
l'installation donc c'était des créneaux
de interventionnelle on peut pas
vraiment parler de chirurgie mais
j'intervenais je mettais des sondes
remplacées des sondes à l'intérieur du
coeur des gens ont regardé un petit peu
ce qu'il en était on en mettait en place
des pacemakers c'est à dire des
stimulateurs cardiaques pour aider le
coeur a pas ralentir de trop ou des
défibrillateurs pour délirer des chocs
électriques chez des gens qui faisaient
des mort subite ou des troubles du
rythme grave
donc il ya aussi cette valence du métier
ce qui est qu'il n'a pas rythmologie que
mon métier là je me contente surtout au
diagnostic mais avant je faisais un
petit peu les interventions qui
permettait de soigner ses problèmes lent
et j'ai aussi des gardes c'est à dire
que là où je travaille j'ai une clinique
qui satisfait à 3,4 garde par semaine ou
sont intensifs de cardiologie et où je
surveille les patients qui sont admis ou
j'admets des patients qui sont très
malades qui ont des problèmes
cardiologiques aiguë qui sont qui font
un infarctus ou qui sont entre
guillemets sur un prêt infarctus quelque
chose comme ça c'est à dire une artère
du coeur qui est qui se bouche ou qui
est en train de se boucher et on les
prend en charge ont fait en sorte qu' il
soit débouchés ou du moins qu'ils soient
correctement traitée avant quand les des
bouches des gens qui sont un choc
cardiogénique c'est à dire avec un
choeur qui fonctionne très très mal avec
de l'insuffisance cardiaque et du coup
il faut aider leur coeur à passer le cap
de ce choc pour le prendre en charge de
l'insuffisance cardiaque de manière
chronique ce que je fais au cabinet à
l'insuffisance cardiaque
voler notre à notre prise en charge mais
il ya aussi les gens qui se déstabilise
dans le cadre de l'insuffisance
cardiaque et qui peuvent en mourir faut
savoir que l'insuffisance cardiaque
terminale
c'est quasiment aussi mortel que les
cancers du poumon au dernier stade donc
c'est une pathologie extrêmement grave
qui est un peu négligés parce que les
gens n'ont pas une image de
l'insuffisance cardiaque comme si
c'était un cancer terminal mais c'est
des gens qu'on va greffer c'est des gens
chez qui on va proposer d assistance des
pompes pour aider le coeur à mieux se
comporter donc tout ça donc ça me fait
ouais un exercice qui est ultra variés
et j'aime bien j'aime bien faire un
petit peu plein de choses d'avoir variés
un petit peu mon exercice de voir plein
de profils de patients différents c'est
à dire je pouvoir des petites dames de
de 30 ans anxieuse comme je peux voir
des vieille dame de 80 ans avec une
insuffisance cardiaque des artères
malades et et plein d'autres pathologies
donc c'est assez cool en fait et on a un
petit peu tout on a vraiment un petit
peu de tout du pas très grave autre est
de fait graves
un des histoires tristes des histoires
marquantes des fois ça m'a non mais
voilà il ya des tas de gens qui font des
trucs des trucs complètement fou où des
gens que ces gens de la vraie vie quoi
et dans la vraie vie ben vous avez des
gens qui sont super intelligent des gens
qui sont super intéressant des gens qui
sont très drôles des gens qui sont très
cons parce que ben les cours ils
s'arrêtent pas d'être con quand il
rentre dans le cabinet je suis désolé
pour eux mais voilà et des fois on a des
gens qui nous raconte des trucs mais
voilà un nom qui pour l'impression que
que voilà qu'ils sont une sorte de
prince où ils ont l'impression d'être au
mcdo des fois signifie beaucoup rire les
passants qui viennent au cabinet et qui
se disent mais je vais pouvoir gueuler
le médecin comme si c'était un jeu c'est
pas n'importe qui dans la rue ou un
serveur voilà on leur dit mais je suis
pas votre service je suis en train de
vous servir un café en fait je suis je
suis là pour vous soigner
enfin voilà il y avait des tas
d'histoires comme ça afin dé foi gens
raconte sur twitter parce que ça me fait
rire quoi mais des gens qui viennent à
avec rien ils savent pas ce qu'ils ont
ils viennent sans papiers ils viennent à
à poil
ils ont pas leurs papiers ils savent pas
ce qu'ils ont et s'appelle traitement
qui prennent ils n'ont pas leurs bilans
biologiques ils vous regardent ils font
alors qu'est ce que j'ai à dire je fais
ce que je peux mais là c'est quand même
pas simple
non disent voilà l'homme et les docteurs
maintenant vous avez qu à regarder sur
internet
ça m'a fait rire aussi c'est certain si
c'était aussi simple que ça je pense que
sans ce marché serait moins utiles quoi
mais bon pourquoi pas non il
les gens sont vraiment poilant en fête
et du veau en termes de charge de trail
en termes de charge de travail
ça dépend quand j'étais quand j'étais
interne on avoisiner les 70 80 heures de
travail hebdomadaires donc on utilise
par deux le bon prendre cinq heures plus
les gardes plus le reste soit on faisait
des bonds 8 heures 21h c'est assez
agressif quand même hein c'est on s'est
compliqué en plus la charge de travail
est lourde
c'est à dire c'est pas 8h 21h02 youpi on
danse on la carioca ou apprendre des
cafés g j'avais des grandes difficultés
pour aller uriner mois typiquement
d'ailleurs on pouvait pas aller pisser
sans que le téléphone soit deux fois
dans votre poche et quand on est jeune
interne en fait on se pose toujours la
question mais si c'est un danger mortel
là il faut que je réponde donc là vous
répondez leur poser sur le 3-2 c'est
incroyable donc voilà bon après on ferme
mesure du temps on le fait plus on dit
bon bah si c'est grave ils rappelleront
quoi mais concrètement moi c'est un truc
qui me stressait beaucoup coualy
téléphone un moment donné j'avais le
téléphone on avait un téléphone pour
donner les avis en fait j'avais
comptabilisé on prenait cent cinquante
150 à 200 appels jours ses demandes
allemandes
ouais mentalement c'est compliqué parce
que tu fais ta journée de travail c'est
à dire que tu bosses tu fais tes trucs
tu vois et 650 fois depuis interrompue
pour des questions diverses et une des
questions les plus crétine aux questions
les plus importantes ou
l'interrogation d'un homme de tes chefs
que tu dois répondre immédiatement
et c'est en termes de charge mentale
en plus du reste plus de la grèce c'est
épouvantable essayer de faire une
consultation et le téléphone sonne cinq
fois essayez de vous souvenir de ce que
vous avez dit aux patients de ça c'est
impossible quoi donc je suis un peu
sorti de sa là je dois je dois faire
c'est un canter plus les gardent donc
après les gardes se rajoute à une nuit
où 24 heures si c'est une gare de
dimanche ou de samedi meiway
concrètement c'est à peu près ça quoi
mais c'est plus léger c'est plus light
quand même elle fait plaisir ça fait
beaucoup plus chaud ça fait pas mal
ouais non mais par rapport à ce que je
faisais d'habitude voilà c'est sait il y
avait une blague qui était qui était un
petit peu comme ça c'est pour ça que
j'ai réussi à faire mes vidéos c'est
parce que j'étais habitué à une recharge
de travail c'était il y avait la blague
du mec dans le désert qui met qui
trimballe une enclume dans le désert et
qui dit mais pourquoi tu trimballe une
enclume dans le désert il dit bien comme
ça si je me fais attaquer par une bête
sauvage je lâche l'enclume et je vais
vachement plus vite et c'est un peu ça
c'est à dire tu lâches l'enclume et du
coup tu sens que tout un champ de
possibles souvent à toi et il ya
vachement plus de trucs à faire une
espèce de vide en fait qui se créent
lorsqu'on travaille un peu moins et moi
je les remplis avec des vidéos sur
youtube et est cool est ce que ça ne
suffisait pas c'est ça et après j'adore
faire des trucs j'adore changer
j'adore être en activité en mouvement
tout le temps pour aller à la fois sur
des nouveaux projets en permanence c'est
quelque chose que j'ai besoin de ça si
on avait des je m'ennuie un peu je fais
je lance un truc dans tout ce qui est
prise en charge en cardiologie à l'esc
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui pourrait
être mieux fait j'ai ce qui pourrait
être mieux fait en cardiologie c'est une
excellente question je saurais pas dire
je pense que l'un des véritables
problèmes qu'on a ça rejoint un petit
peu d'autres problématiques que j'aborde
c'est la pédagogie la compréhension des
patients au travers de ce qu'on fait il
ya une image de ce que fait le médecin
et du rôle du médecin et des objectifs
du médecin qui est fantasmé au sein de
la société c'est-à-dire que les gens ont
aucune idée en fait deux sur l'emploi
composent notre journée et sur ce qu'on
fait et sur ceux et de ce qu'on dit et
des gens fantasment un peu les trucs et
où une vision qui est très biaisée par
la société en général aussi par les
médias de comment on prescrit de comment
est-ce qu'on réfléchisse autour de la
médecine c'est à dire que les gens je
sais pas sont persuadés d'une manière ou
d'une autre on gagne de l'argent si on
prescrit plus un médicament
ce n'est pas vrai ça c est ça le salaire
pour ceux que je reçois moi c'est bien
les gens que je soigne un jeu cote entre
lee mais l'acte que j'ai fait c'est à
dire si je fais une échographie jeudi
ben j'ai fait une échographie et la sécu
rembourse le tarif d'une échographie
quoi c'est juste ça qui se passe après
la prescription des médicaments c'est à
dire ce qu'on prescrit
c'est ce qu'ont fait vis-à-vis des
patients et les patients ont
l'impression que on doit leur prescrire
des médicaments pour leur faire plaisir
et c'est pas comme ça qu'on fonctionne
on a des recommandations de sociétés
savantes
on regarde si le patient rentrer dans
une case dans une autre c'est à dire si
mon patient étant d'insuffisance
cardiaque avec une fraction d'éjection
de temps avec elle critères tels
critères on sait de manière scientifique
c'est à dire qu'il ya une étude qu'il
approuvait que tel médicament va lui
apporter un bénéfice en termes de
morbidité ou de mortalité c'est à dire
qu'il va - mourir qui va moins faire de
complications qui va moins faire de
problème est en fait il est patiente
juste bave si je sais pourquoi mais les
patients sont persuadés en fait que
quand ils sont en insuffisance cardiaque
qui sont très essoufflé à cause de la
perte de leur insuffisance cardiaque
sont toujours persuadés que c'est le
médicament le problème toujours c'est à
dire qu' il dise oh là là je suis
essoufflée 7 puis qu'on avait mis le
médicament et on a redit non c'est je
vous ai mis le médicament parce que vous
êtes dix journées et manifestement il ne
suffit pas parce que vous êtes toujours
essoufflé donc on va essayer de
travailler un petit peu plus et il ya
beaucoup de mesures hygiéno diététiques
qui sont compliqués qui sont très
importantes en cardiologie très très
importante
les régime sans sel l'accompagnement des
patients enfin un régime sans sel
c'est à dire d'essayer de manger moins
salé ce que le régime sans sel c'est
intenable de toute façon donc c'est en
train d'être retirée mais d'essayer de
manger moins salé d'essayer de faire
plus d'exercice de se mettre plus en
forme d'essayer de manger mieux de
manger moins tout ça c'est quelque chose
qui est ultra important est que les
patients ne néglige les patients sont
dans une espèce de croyance que le
médicament va tout résoudre c'est à dire
il ya toujours un cachet pour chaque
problème est que le médicament doit tout
résoudre mais qu'en même temps de
médicaments parmi les craignent aussi un
peu toxiques
donc il faut pas en prendre il faut
juste comprendre quand ça va pas et
c'est pas du tout comme ça qu'on
fonctionne c'est à dire que nous quand
on nomme patients atteints
d'insuffisance cardiaque
ça se guérit pas en fait c'est à dire
que le patient est là par exemple il a
fait un infarctus et la cram et la
moitié de son coeur la moitié de son
coeur la nécrose et sa part vivre donc
nous on essaie de compenser avec les
médicaments
s'ils arrêtent les médicaments ils vont
se déstabiliser mais tout simplement
donc et les gens comprennent pas ce
système de prévention ce système de
rouffach signe parce que si vous faites
la grippe et que vous êtes en
insuffisance cardiaque vous allez décédé
oui mais là je vais bien certes mais si
vous faites la grippe alors vous êtes en
insuffisance cardiaque
vous avez des compenser une insuffisance
cardiaque est déjà sévère vous allez
mourir
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
compliqué pour les gens de la même
manière le traitement au long cours pour
l'hypertension hypertension ces espèces
de tueur silencieux c'est pareil que le
diabète c'est à dire que ça tue pas
d'emblée c'est pas parce que vous avez
16 de tension qui va se passer un truc
terrible dans la minute quoi mais au
bout de dix quinze ans vous allez
développer des lésions et vous allez
avoir un risque d'avc qui va être
triplés quintuplé ou en risque de faire
une maladie coronaire qui va être
multiplié par deux par trois et ça c'est
compliqué de dire aux gens vous allez
prendre ce médicament
ça va rien faire mais peut-être dans
cinq ans on ferait pas un infarctus ça
mentalement c'est très très compliqué à
comprendre mais c'est parce que nos
politiques de santé publique
elles sont faibles c'est à dire que il
ya peu de politiques incitatives pour
dire aux gens à les voir une
diététicienne prenez en charge votre
poids votre surpoids parce que
un marketing agroalimentaire qui est
très agressif qui est très présent il y
a un peu d'interventions
d'accompagnement chez les patients qui
sont un petit peu limité
intellectuellement quant à la prise de
leur traitement et tout ça c'est très
compliqué d'accompagner un patient qui
est un peu limité ou que vous sentez pas
terribles ou même tout simplement qu'ils
parlent pas français
parce que j'allais patients moi je suis
au centre ville en fête dehors de la
ville dans laquelle j'exerce j'ai une
population maghrébine qui est très
importante de maghrébins qui parlent pas
français
c'est très compliqué déjà la compliance
d'un médicament quand on comprend bien
ce qu'il en est que le médecin vous
expliquer c'est chaud c'est à dire que
vous avez des défauts de compliance à 5
ans qui sont à 40 % c'est-à-dire 40% des
patients qui prennent pas correctement
ou plus du tout leur traitement
c'est quand même pas terrible mais si en
plus vous prenez des populations chez
qui il est difficile de communiquer
parce que vous n'avez pas la maîtrise de
la langue ou qu'ils comprennent pas
parce qu ils ont des limitations
intellectuelles c'est compliqué et que
c'est pas tous des csp + curieux de leur
santé tout ça ben c'est plus c'est
difficile c'est vraiment difficile avec
ces populations et on manque de ça pour
les accompagner et en plus comme je lé
souvent dénoncé il ya des campagnes de
désinformation vis-à-vis des traitements
souvent des mecs qui sortent en disant
que ou là les vaccins c'est toxique ça
fait mal et du coup tous les médias
reprennent ça d'emblée des campagnes
pour dire que je sais pas que des
enfants naissent tous avec une tête
perdus et qu'ils ont besoin de faire des
séances d'ostéopathie pour les remettre
en place ce qui est complètement fou
enfin voilà et cette ambiance entre lee
mais de désinformation de fond à une
espèce de politiques alarmistes où tout
le monde est malade tout le monde est
plus ou moins intoxiquées par des trucs
des machins
c'est quelque chose qui nous dessert ou
long pour vraiment ça rend toutes les
consultations difficile ça rend toutes
les prescriptions
complexe difficile parce qu'elles sont
tentés de je sais pas je ne sais quoi de
complotisme nul qu'il faut déconstruire
avant de pouvoir faire son travail
correctement et c'est extrêmement
difficile déjà c'est compliqué de
soigner des gens parce que c'est
compliqué de soigner les gens si en plus
on a des difficultés parce que il ya je
ne sais pas quel vieux professeur à la
retraite qui a dit que tous les
antidépresseurs était mortel ou parce
que il ya un autre professeur qui dit
que l'eau se souvient de tel truc et que
du coup ça se soigne le cancer et le vih
c'est insupportable on y arrive plus
quoi c'est vraiment se font d'eux des
informations scientifiques à mon avis
qui est extrêmement problématique dans
la population parce qu'il fout la merde
dans notre métier quoi ballon et il rêve
le pronostic des gens aussi clairement
quelqu'un qui prend pas son traitement
parce qu'il est persuadé que je paca big
pharma derrière ou quoi c'est quelqu'un
qui au final se soigne pas quoi et
quelqu'un qui soit une passe quelqu'un
qui marche plutôt pas sait jamais la
désinformation et jamais au bénéfice du
patient jamais du coup tout ça c'est un
peu s'effacer est-ce que c'était ta
motivation pour se lancer dans la
vulgarisation du youtube
la motivation je sais pas c'était
surtout entre guillemets une idée l'idée
derrière c'était de parler du sujet
intéressant d'évoquer la méthode
scientifique c'est à dire je me suis dit
je me suis dit il ya beaucoup de
désinformation c'est à dire que vous
tapez n'importe quoi sur internet on
entend énormément de conneries c'est à
dire en sentez vous tapez à n'importe
quel un truc vous allez tomber sur un
forum ou chez un sur un blog d'un
praticien peu scrupuleux qui va vous
raconter de la merde et moi ça me saoule
et par exemple qu'on raconte n'importe
quoi sur les vaccins que les premières
ressources en fait que vous êtes
disponible sur les vaccins ce soit des
sites de désinformation antivaccinal que
les premières ressources que vous avez
quand vous parlez de lives et gb soit
des trucs complètement con quoi et
l'idée c'était de dire il y a des
ressources disponibles sur internet qui
sont cali qui sont qualitatifs qui sont
visés qu'ils ont un certain backup
scientifique derrière et même si elles
ont une forme qui est agréable une forme
qui est
sympa parce qu'il fallait aussi que ce
soit sympa un minimum fallait pas que ce
soit jean michel austérité vous parle de
la médecine parce que sinon on touche
pas son coeur de cible mais moi mon
coeur de cible c'était vraiment le grand
public il fallait que ce soit sympa il
fallait que ce soit disponible et que ce
soit compréhensible pour le grand public
est vraiment que les gens se disent je
passe un bon moment et j'apprends des
trucs on a peu l'idée l'idée c'est ce
que certains de mes collègues fond
c'était un peu de lait clic bt avec un
contenu qui est un peu coloré un petit
peu sympa et au final ils sortent de la
vidéo en se disant ah [ __ ] je me suis
fait avoir j'ai appris plein de trucs
c'était un peu c'est un peu l'idée un
peu ce que je m'étais dit après la lutte
contre la désinformation elle est venue
plus tard c'est à dire c'est après les
différentes remarques que j'ai eu autour
de ma d'une vidéo sur les vaccins au
début je vais faire comme plus très
classique puis j'avais fait un truc sur
les vaccins avec une copine à moi avec
un avec pauline à meillonnas juste salue
d'ailleurs inquiets qui s'occupa
peut-être pas dire son nom mais pas
grave qui s'occupe de la d'une chaîne
qui était vachement bien sûr sur
l'immunité qui s'appelait à un peu
pointu qui était inquiété excellente qui
élimine log et qui est vachement forte
et je me suis dit on va faire un truc
sur les vaccins et je m'en suis sorti
avec des vagues d'un sud avec des
vomissements une espèce de franges de la
population qui était complètement
inféodées à ce genre d'idées et ça m'a
beaucoup posé de questions je me suis
beaucoup posé de question de pourquoi ce
truc a pris sur les gens pourquoi est ce
qu'on croit ce genre de choses
pourquoi est ce que on a tendance à
virer du quotidien anti-vaccins c'est
vachement intéressant en fait c'est
pourquoi est ce que le discours
scientifique ne prend pas parce qu'il
est logique mon discours un canton dit
baisse et des petits morceaux de la
bactérie en question ou du virus en
question
on va le montrer à votre système
immunitaire il va créer ses propres
défenses et voilà c'est un truc c'est
étudié je crois au collège en cinquième
ou quatrième un truc comme ça c'est
étudié au collège c'est quelque chose
qui est parfaitement accessible d'un
esprit humain pourquoi est-ce qu'on va
rentrer dans une logique qui va à
l'encontre complètement de ça pourquoi
est-ce qu'on va tomber dans un espèce de
complotisme bizarre
mais médical et ça m'a amené beaucoup de
questions vis-à-vis de tout ça ça m'a
amené à comprendre que effectivement la
culture scientifique au sein de la
population
eh ben c'est pas ouf vraiment c'est à
dire que c'est pas leur faute c'est mais
s'il n'y a pas grand-chose qui stimule
la culture scientifique
y a pas grand chose qui amène à remettre
en question les gens sont pas armés pour
lire les études là je vois beaucoup de
gens en fait sur les réseaux sociaux qui
interviennent et qui me demandent les
sources de ce que je raconte je leur
dise très bien je peux te sortir un
article du new gm mais tu sais pas le
lire c'est ça n'a aucun intérêt c'est
pas c'est pas lui dit que c'est pas
didactique c'est ultra complexes c'est
un truc de médecins qui s'adresse aux
médecins c'est c'est comme tout si je te
demandais un truc en maths que je te
demande était source tu va me sortir des
trucs bien vénère avec des
mathématiciens ultra complexes mais
c'est pas le but même si jette un sort
ce jeudi à dire ok c'est super mais j'ai
rien compris parce que j'y comprends
rien déjà mois le théorème de pythagore
c'est chaud donc voilà donc tu vois je
manque de base à ce niveau là donc c'est
pas c'est pas très pertinent tu vois
d'arriver et de d'être dans cette espèce
de dialectique de des banques parce que
de toute façon tu peut débloquer ce
genre de truc mille fois tu peut contrer
des tas d'arguments qui sont faux c'est
très bien mais les gens entre guillemets
rentrer à une réalité complexe
voilà qui comprennent pas et l'espèce de
trucs fantasmer qui correspond mieux à
leurs aspirations ou à leur vision du
monde mais qui est complètement faux qui
est complètement con il le complexifie
aussi suffisamment pour que les gens se
disent non mais ça a l'air sérieux là
utilisent des mots des mots un peu chaud
il doit connaître un peu son sujet et
les gens fêtent ce filles principalement
à ça et comme on disait de toute façon
la dialectique antivaccinal c'est
toujours les mêmes arguments et c'est
une sorte de millefeuille argumentatif 1
comme ils disent c'est à dire c'est
plein plein plein d'arguments diffusé en
flux qui tue mes diplômes bas à contrer
chacun à chaque argument qu'il faut qui
est fallacieux mais au final voilà il ya
peu d'intérêt et il ya historique avait
sorti une vidéo là-dessus l'assureur sur
le titanic ça n'a aucun rapport et qui
qui sortait un petit peu de cette
logique qui disait il faut se poser des
questions extrêmement simple plutôt que
d'essayer de débloquer
c'est à dire de critiquer se les donner
convient de vous apporter et d'essayer
d'apporter entre guillemets une
démonstration argumentée du caractère
fallacieux de la démonstration qui vous
est fait il faudrait plutôt arriver sur
la logique de base c'est à dire pourquoi
est ce qu'il y aura un complot mondial
pour vacciner les gens ainsi il ya
quelques années le nombre de gens que ça
mobiliserait pour essayer de masquer le
complot quelle est l'idée derrière tout
ça est ce que c'est vraiment pertinent
de faire un complot là dessus est ce que
à un moment donné il y aura pas
quelqu'un qui aurait vendu la mèche à ce
que c'est vraiment pertinent est ce que
voilà et de poser des questions plus ou
moins de forme moins sur le fond
argumentaire qui est volontairement
entre guillemets falsifiés abîmé pour
faire en sorte que de faire passer les
idées que là que la personne vous faire
passer plutôt se questionner sur
l'objectif de la personne sur les
modalités qui font que sur la manière
dont on aborde la chose je pense que
c'est plus intéressant
je pense que moi quand je me retrouve
confronté à quelqu'un j'ai plutôt
tendance maintenant à poser des
questions alors demandé mais pourquoi tu
penses à pourquoi est ce que tu as est
ce que le fonds de la théorie te paraît
cohérent est ce que le fait de penser
que les vaccins sont un complot à un
complot magique ça te paraît intéressant
judicieux est-ce que ça paraît pertinent
et très rapidement les gens dont 19 donc
pas trop quand même pas ce que c'est
il ya plein de failles en attendant ce
raisonnement là et on peut avancer c'est
quand même beaucoup plus un plus un toit
qui veut débattre mieux je trouve que
ouais moi j'arrive un peu à la fin de
cette stratégie du débat c'est bien de
donner des arguments mais au final
comment dire ça légitime un petit peu
l'interlocuteur qu'on a en face quoi
c'est à dire ça si je passe mon temps à
des banques est un vieux mec moisissures
les réseaux sociaux en slip qui me sort
la dialectique antivaccinal que j'ai
entendu vingt mille fois
je perds mon temps si j'étais en quête
perdu oui il est perdu pour la cause ça
sert à rien donc je préfère prendre mon
temps de discuter avec les gens qui sont
ouverts qui sont un peu indécis et de
laisser cette dialectique entre
guillemets à ceux que ça intéresse quoi
qu'elles sont à pagnol et les raisons
profondes pour lesquelles les anti
vaccin anti vaccins les raisons
profondes il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont et qui sont mises en cause je tiens
à préciser un truc c'est que j'ai aucune
animosité vis-à-vis des gens qui sont
ivax des gens qui sont tombés dans une
espèce de logique pervertie et qu'ils se
sont dit voilà cette solution paraît
être la mieux je pense que ce sont des
victimes
vraiment c'est à dire des victimes d'un
système qui est là pour les manipuler et
qui veut là pour les embêter je suis
beaucoup plus véhéments vis-à-vis des
gens qui falsifient les données qui
manipule qui manifestement ont les
connaissances c'est à dire les médecins
qui soutiennent ce genre de procès sans
guillemets pour des raisons bassement
mercantiles ou pour essayer de vendre
des bouquins ou des conférences comme le
font certains ça ça me pose plus
problème mais par contre les gens qui
sont audi vaccin il ya beaucoup de
choses qu'il explique en général c'est
un drame humain c'est à dire que les
gens qui sont anti vaccins je vais vous
dire quelque chose de très simple c'est
une maman par exemple qui va avoir son
gamin qui va être autiste qui va
attraper une épilepsie
dans mon entourage là j'ai vu quelqu'un
son fils à une épilepsie ce qu'on
appelle un syndrome de west une
épilepsie on acquiert vers l'âge de neuf
mois nan quelque chose comme ça avec un
pronostic dégradé sur le plan cognitif
tout ça c'est à dire que là il sera
éloigné retard mental il aura en retard
d acquisition ça va être compliqué c'est
une maladie qui est dur à gérer des
traitement au long cours a suivi
particulier c'est dur vous vous
retrouvez dans une situation dure
difficile à ce moment là qu'est ce que
qu'est ce que va faire cette personne
elle va se dire c'est de ma faute c'est
de ma faute j'ai fait un truc machin qui
fait que mon enfant a attrapé ça sauf
que non sauf qu'en vérité c'est un cas
sur ge pas de
mille 5000 10000 et la personne même
tomber sur nos vélos c'est à dire on a
tiré le mauvais ticket mais ça c'est pas
une explication qui est satisfaisant
pour les gens de dire bah c'est une
modification génétique ou c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'explique pas bien il faut
du sens il faut expliquer un truc et là
vous allez vous poser des questions sur
ce qui s'est passé dans l'entourage de
l'enfant et vous allez vous poser des
questions sur est ce que mon enfant a
été exposé à la pollution oui tu nous as
we made you qui passe un comté où il est
exposé à la pollution
c'est peut-être la pollution dont vous
allez être entré dans une logique c'est
la pollution qui a abîmé bon enfant et
toussaint très bien ça peut être un des
composants du biberon et vous allez
incriminé le bisphénol a qui est un
composant du biberon qui a été vaguement
incriminé un moment donné et le
bisphénol a peut être responsable
99 % des enfants ayant été exposées au
biberon vous avez trouvé toujours des
gens qui vont être d'accord avec cette
théorie toujours c'est à dire il ya des
gens moi aussi mon enfant il a utilisé
un biberon moi aussi là un syndrome de
west et vous allez faire un lien logique
et ce lien logique
il a entre guillemets une consonance
très forte pour le patient c'est à dire
c'est très important pour lui c'est très
très important c'est fondamental pour
lui parce que ça donne du sens la
maladie elle est arrivée il ya une pause
bien établie et je vais pouvoir
combattre cette cause et je vais pouvoir
convaincre les gens les fabricants de
biberons les fabricants les des
fabriques temps de pots d'échappement et
les fabricants de vaccin parce que tout
enfant tout enfant a été vacciné au
moins une fois
de toute façon soit avec le dtp soit
avec les vaccins machin donc tout enfant
a été vaccinée donc vous tapez vaccins
et épilepsie vaccin autisme vaccin
pathologies de n'importe quel enfant
vous allez trouver un groupe de parents
qui vont avoir fait le même lien logique
et là vous rentrer dans ce qu'on appelle
le biais de confirmation
c'est à dire que vous allez avoir tout
un tas de témoignages qui vont dans le
même sens
moi aussi mon enfant a été vaccinée à
ses six mois à neuf mois il a développé
quelques rues moi aussi je les vaccinés
à 6 mois parce qu il est recommandé de
le vacciner six mois et il a développé
tel truc voilà
c'est il y avait un peu ce lien qui
avait été fait avec l'hépatite b et la
sclérose en plaques en france c'est à
dire que on faisait la vaccination
hépatite b parce que c'est une maladie
dans les pays occidentaux surtout par sa
sexuellement transmissibles il
yad'autres transmission de l'hépatite b
me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
dit mais il y à une transmission
sexuelle et donc on vacciner les gamines
à 15 ans et à cet âge là entre
guillemets à ces jeunes adultes se
développe la sclérose en plaques dont on
n'explique pas bien entre guillemets
comment ça survient on a des facteurs
favorisants mais on sait pas trouver du
coutach il ya un maximum de gens quand
on fait ce lien hépatite b sclérose en
plaques et il a suffi de déplacés entre
limay de la vaccination hépatite b dans
l'enfance dé ce lien est beaucoup moins
évident pour les gens de bazens c'est
parce que parce que c'est logique les
pendants prenant long moment
ce lien hépatite b sclérose en plaques
qui n'existe pas je le répète a été
incriminé des associations patients des
gens qui se sont plaints effectivement
ces gens sont en détresse ces gens ont
une maladie brave dégénérative avec un
potentiel handicap ont trouvé un
coupable éventuelles et ont besoin d'une
réparation ont besoin de se sentir
écouté pris en charge mieux et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il aura été reconnu par
les tribunaux mais malheureusement il
n'y a pas de lien scientifiquement
établie entre hépatite b sclérose en
plaques et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est problématique et cette logique anti
vaccins elle n'est de ça elle n'est de
une histoire que vous allez entendre un
truc émotionnel tout ça du fait que des
gens sans graisse là dessus c'est un mec
comme professeur joyeux ou d'autres
personnes qui vendent des bouquins
là-dessus font leur beurre là dessus
c'est à dire ils font de l'argent sur la
détresse de ses parents de ses patients
qui veulent trouver une explication qui
sont en quête de sens vis-à-vis de tout
ça d
malheureusement ces gens là où on pas la
ressource n'ont pas les compétences
scientifiques pour pouvoir critiquer ce
discours là est la logique est
tautologique de toute façon dans une
logique complotistes c'est à dire que si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec eux vous
faites partie du complot et comme vous
faites partie du complot tout ce que
vous allez pouvoir dire ne sert à rien
et donc c'est extrêmement compliqué de
rentrer là dedans donc l'objet ce serait
vraiment de donner les armes aux gens
songent à interdire les armes de
compréhension de ce qu'est un vaccin de
ce qu'est un adjuvant d'à quoi ça sert
les sels d'aluminium tout ça de manière
générale à la population générale pour
qu'au moment où elles sont confrontées à
ce genre de discours à un moment de
vulnérabilité
peut-être ça va ticket ils vont dire
dans le vif il ya un truc qui va pas
passer pas c'est pas comme ça ça ne
marche pas comme ça et que ça puisse
leur permettre d'échapper un petit peu à
ça parce que ce sont des mécaniques
toujours les mêmes sont des mécaniques
d'emprise en fait c'est de l'emprise
mentale c'est à dire que vous arrivez
c'est toujours les mêmes populations qui
sont ciblés les patients atteints de
maladies chroniques est grave
les cancéreux à les patients malades du
cancer
les jeunes mamans les femmes enceintes
c'est les populations qui sont sur une
phase de transition avec un truc qui va
leur arriver prochainement sur la
perspective de la mort soit une
grossesse c'est un changement corporels
complets un changement du rapport au
corps et ces gens là sont vulnérables et
ces gens vulnérables sont très poreux à
sans avoir un enfant malade sa rentrée
très vulnérables c'est-à-dire que ils
sont ok de quelqu'un qui va leur dire
rassurez vous je vais m'occuper de vous
et j'ai une solution très simple et
c'est parce qu'on propose en médecine en
médecine on propose bert à un abord
rationnelle la vérité mais pas forcément
un truc vraiment ultra cool entendre
c'est pas cool d'entendre que le
traitement de l'autisme glace un peu
compliquer la prise en charge est lourde
complexe tout ça la prise en charge
d'une anomalie chromosomique hommes
trisomie c'est pas on va faire une cure
d'antibiotiques pendant trois semaines
ça va aller mieux ça marche pas comme ça
c'est ce qu'on peut vous vendre mais ça
marche pas comme ça donc là dessus c'est
il ya beaucoup c'est mécanique
d'entreprise qui sont là et c'est
vraiment un truc qui est problématique
en médecine parce que ouais c'est des
gens vulnérables et c'est des gens qui
profitent de quoi tout simplement du
gossip essai de récapitulatif du
monument aux morts mais la pression que
j'ai c'est que du coup pour beaucoup de
gens en fait il y a
franck est en général on attend ça
donnait beaucoup d'importance à
identifier un responsable ou un coupable
il ya toujours une quête de cause la
quête d'une cause et en plus j'imagine
que sur les vaccins en particulier comme
comme ça c'est un événement enfin voila
c'est un événement ces marques ont passé
et en plus ce qui paraît dévié peut-être
un biais naturaliste on a tendance à
penser que si on faisait rien les
choisir vient du coup comme comme si une
intervention s'est du coup ça c'est près
de ça c'est ça il ya il ya une forme de
pensée entre lee mais qu' il vaut mieux
rester à ne rien faire plutôt que de
faire une intervention et que une
intervention sera par force plus
délétère parce qu'il ya des mécanismes
entre libé intrinsèque ce qu'on appelle
des biais cognitifs de surestimation du
risque on va toujours surestimé le
risque par rapport aux bénéfices
attendus le bénéfice d'un vaccin
antirougeoleux par exemple il est très
fort un enfant votre enfant qui fait pas
la rougeole c'est très important parce
que la rougeole peut avoir des
complications une fois sur cent des
complications neurologiques et un décès
une fois sur 1000
c'est gravissime c'est à dire un enfant
sur mille qui meurt c'est insupportable
un enfant sur 1 million qui meurt c'est
insupportable surtout quand c'est
évitable et on a à côté un risque minime
principalement qu'il est allergique ou
quai d'un rachat de quelque chose comme
ça c'est à dire d'une effets secondaires
du vaccin qui est microscopique à côté
qui est de une fois sur un million sur
un milliard et on a tendance à
surestimer ce risque et on a tendance à
faire des mauvaises des mauvaises
association tient bon à mon enfant a
développé une maladie qui se développe
pendant l'enfance un cancer nous et les
cancers de la moelle osseuse qui vont se
développer des lymphomes des leucémies
tout ça qui vont se développer à ces
âges là c'est facile de faire le lien
avec les vaccins et c'est encore plus
facile pour un professionnel de santé
d'appuyer là dessus bagnards d'aller
dire ouais je pense que quand même c'est
pas terrible et vaccins ce pas terrible
aussi de manger tel truc ou de faire tel
truc ou de l'amener à tel endroit parce
il ya des ondes électromagnétiques tout
ça c'est facile de raconter un char à
quelqu'un qui a envie de vous croire qui
a envie de vous fait confiance
et parce que vous êtes dans une dans une
situation de vulnérabilité et et le
discours entre guillemets c'est à dire
l'exposition de notre côté d'un faible
risque c'est un risque quand même il n'y
a pas cette limite quand vous êtes avec
quelqu'un qui essaie d'avoir une emprise
sur nous personne ne vous dis pas ouais
il ya une chance sur dix mille que votre
rate explose ça n'arrive jamais c'est
tombé sur un charlatan le charlatan elle
vous dit vous inquiétez pas dans un mois
on sera fixé ça va aller mieux et si ça
va pas mieux c'est un peu de votre faute
parce que vous l'avez pas fait tout à
fait comme il faut ouais donc c'est
quand même c'est trop simple c'est
beaucoup trop simple et nous on est dans
une démarche plus rationnelle mais qui
peut-être pas bien comprise parce que
bell et jean sont en quête de solutions
de facilité de ça ait de solution
consommables il ya beaucoup de saliha et
il ya beaucoup voilà il ya aussi
l'exposition médiatique si vous passez
votre temps à médiatiser je sais pas
quel est l'enfoiré qui vend un bouquin
pour dire du mal des vaccins les vaccins
ça fait peur si vous passez votre temps
à médiatiser l'histoire de madame michu
acquis que son fils il a attrapé à je
sais pas quel cancer abominable qu'il en
est décédé et que bizarrement trois
semaines avant de le découvrir en avec
ciné sangosse ben ouais il n'y a pas de
bien c'est vrai mais dans la tête de des
gens ça fait ça fout les jetons quoi
ouais ça pose question et après quand
vous tapez bizarrement quand vous tapez
vaccin maladie abominable et bien vous
tombez sur tout un tas de discours
affreux de jean anxiogène de maman
éplorée qui vous disent avec moi aussi
j'ai vacciner mon enfant à neuf mois et
badaboum à il a développé cette maladie
infantile
c'est ses complexes c'est pour ça que le
discours anti vaccins il a beaucoup
prises dans la population et que c'est
compliqué de le déconstruire machin
parce que il profite à certaines
personnes clairement il ya deux ans
des bouquins là dessus évidemment on n'a
pas bien pas lieu d'aller dire non mais
les vaccins en fait c'est cool manger en
quoi donc
il ya ce bel arbre qui ce genre de
message consiste à rejeter la faute avec
souvent un peu de colère ou d'énervement
sur un truc en particulier c'est quelque
chose qui est très viral 400 messages
très facilement mais c'est super simple
en fait votre aide et votre esprit c'est
nous nouons 1er mai comme scientifique
on est très content avec ça mais on a
tendance à vouloir chercher une
explication rationnelle à questionner
notre rapport au réel
les gens en fait ils sont sur une
réponse très émotionnel très épidermique
en fait et c'est simple allez expliquer
que je sais pas que le lymphome à va se
développer sur certains facteurs de
risques mais pas à chaque fois c'est pas
parce que vous êtes exposés au tabagisme
passif que votre enfant va développer un
cancer un peu plus mais pas à chaque
fois que il ya une question génétique
dessous qui a un peu d'épis génétique
aussi qu'il ya des questions
d'environnement mais qui a pas que
l'environnement
si c'est cher c'est compliqué c'est les
gens et 10 ouais mais c'est à cause de
quoi
c'est pourquoi pourquoi moi pas tous les
autres enfants ils vont bien moins le
miel va pas bien pourquoi moi ce qu'est
ce que j'ai fait de moins bien que les
autres
un débat s'est battu quoi et c'est
inacceptable d'entendre c'est pas de cul
donc on va chercher du sens et quand il
ya quelqu'un qui arrive et qui vous dit
non mais c'est ce qui met dans les
biberons
c'est nickel si super c'est super c'est
super facile c'est super simple il ya
une mono explication à ça voilà où c'est
le fait d'avoir utilisé du lait de vache
est le lait de vache voilà c'est méchant
voilà et c'est compliqué on peut pas
dire aux jambes elle les âges ce méchant
tu vas chez lui ni méchants des gentils
il est 9h quoi c'est c'est comme les
médicaments le médicament la bêta
bloquants c'est ce que je dis aux
patients et dénis méchants des gentils
ils aident à gérer une situation puis là
des effets secondaires alors parce que
c'est un bêtabloquant quoi donc c'est un
médicament donc sa semaine pas comme
comme un bonbon fait pas n'importe quoi
avec
mais il peut nous dépanner dans cette
situation là et si on ne prend pas on
prend des risques
donc est ce qu'on fait et les gens le
comprennent mais ça met du temps c'est
difficile
et quand vous leur avait raconté une
grosse connerie avant mais c'est
vachement plus dur quand même parce que
s'ils sont persuadés que le médicament
que le vaccin ou le truc déjà de base
ils ont a priori négatifs dessus ils
vont pas de show chaud à d'emblée quoi
alors que bon s'ils ont reçu une
information globalement objective pas
trop anxiogène
ils sont plus réceptifs ils comprennent
voilà c'est plus c'est plus simple pour
tout le monde quoi
donc ouais ouais du coup du coup parce
que là du coup ici aussi jeux gc
identifié quelques points clés des
raisons pour lesquelles les antilles
avec son hôte ivax donc il me semble
vraiment qu'on peut identifier le fait
que c'est cette quête d'un responsable
d'un coupable qui est très rare et
points donc c'est essayer peut-être
expliquer que bassong choses sont
compliquées et il faut accepter que les
choses sont compliquées que c'est
multifactoriel et que les avants ça se
réduit pas un coupable
la plupart du temps c'est ça des fois
vous avez une bactérie bombay c'est la
bactérie qui est responsable du truc
c'est assez facile donc voilà une belle
bactérie mais après notre question qu'on
peut se poser c'est mais pourquoi la
bactérie chez moi elle provoque sa il
pas chez quelqu'un d'autre pourquoi
est-ce que machin parce que les
variations interindividuelles tout ça
est extrêmement complexe et extrêmement
complexe et le corps humain et la
compréhension de de ce compte de ce
qu'on est et de ce qu'on va devenir par
rapport à tout ça c'est extrêmement
compliqué et les explications mono
factorielle et tout ce qui est absurde
au médecine basée là-dessus c'est
extrêmement simple à comprendre
c'est fait pour ça c'est fait pour être
prêt simple à comprendre vous allez voir
un naturopathe
tout est la faute de votre alimentation
si vous bouffez mieux vous êtes peu de
maladies c'est un peu compliqué que ça
si vous voulez c'est une partie du
problème mais c'est compliqué que ça et
on peut pas laisser dire que
l'alimentation
dans le vélo blé ou la consommation de
viande rouge va résoudre tous les
problèmes chez quelqu'un c'est
malhonnête et et on est il ya aussi un
point qui est important et sur lequel on
n'insiste pas assez c'est que dans notre
société est aujourd'hui on n'accepte pas
la notion d'incertitude et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est complexe
c'est à dire que de bataille du coup les
gens les gens ne peuvent pas de
concevoir que l'on vous répondre je ne
sais pas où je n'y a pas d'explication à
proprement parler et la gestion de
l'incertitude dans le grand public
vis-à-vis de la médecine
c'est insupportable c'est à dire que
tout devrait être sujet à un principe de
précaution absolu c'est à dire que les
médicaments jeux faudrait tester pendant
15 ans c'est pas possible pas testé un
médicament pendant 15 ans avant de le
mettre sur le marché parce qu'il ya des
gens qui sont malades et des gens qui
vont décéder donc on les met sur marché
et il ya un petit risque
il ya toujours un petit doute y a il n'y
a pas de solution à 102% satisfaisante
il ya beaucoup de critiques par exemple
vis-à-vis du vaccin contre la grippe les
gens disent oh il est efficace qu'à 50%
oui mais c'est vrai c'est bien mais
c'est déjà pas mal s'aggraver
c'est ça va enfin voilà des fois des
fois c'est plus j'ai des fois c'est moi
mais on dit voilà il est une efficacité
qui est pas partout le même parce que
plusieurs variantes du virus tout ça
parce que c'est plus compliqué que ça il
ya des gens qui disent ouais mais si
c'est pas efficace à 100% ça ne
m'intéresse pas m'ayant qu'un médicament
qui est efficace à 100% j'ai patients
qui sont en insuffisance cardiaque
on met les bêtabloquants parce que c'est
mieux mais j'ai des gens sous les
tableaux quand ça va mieux j'ai des gens
je peux tableau quand ça change pas
grand chose et des gens ça ne va pas du
tout c'est même pire
donc tu m'adapte jeu on s'adapte aux
situations cliniques on essaie quand
même de faire un effort quoi parce qu'un
médicament qui augmente leur survie ça
vaut quoi
même le temps tu es fou quand même un
peu ce se faire un défaut un peu
violence pour enfin on essaye
bien sûr laisse pas abattre sur un effet
secondaire nul ou luz y aura là j'ai
saigné du nez le lendemain ça doit être
le méta bloquant parce qu'une bêta
bloquants de ne pas ce genre d'effets
secondaires donc clôture pour expliquer
faudra passer du temps que ça mais c'est
long c'est compliqué et l'acceptation
tout ça et il ya une incertitude entre
l'inné serment extrêmement complexe de
faire admettre aux gens que des fois on
ne sait pas que des fois c'est compliqué
que dia des fois des mécanismes d'action
comprend pas qu'il ya des choses qu'on
comprend très bien et que du coup il
faudrait quand même faire malgré tout
c'est à dire qu'il ya des trucs on a
très bien compris que ça marchait pas
mais on continue de le faire et ça c'est
très énervant et ça faudrait pouvoir le
corriger et il ya des trucs voilà on en
sait juste rien et c'est pas parce que
il ya aussi d'autres choix il ya des
fois il sait pas parce que c'est un truc
qui est hyper mystérieux que c'est
forcément intéressant j'ai des tas de
trucs voilà c'est pas parce que ça a
l'air hyper bizarre que ça va forcément
avoir un intérêt clinique parce qu'elle
me quantique etc etc c'est ça c'est pas
parce que parce que tu étais embrouille
le machin tu te tuer' en robe est une
espèce de truc en parlant de mécanique
quantique ou de phénomènes ondulatoires
que que ça forcément un intérêt ou que
c'est forcément intéressant et c'est pas
parce que on n'y comprend rien qu'on
peut pas en mesurer les effets
biologiques quelque chose qui est
complexe c'est à dire que ça c'est nos
copains homéopathe
par exemple nous explique que on
comprend rien l'homéopathie mais c'est
bon faites nous confiance ça marche pas
comme ça
c'est est ce qu'on a des effets mesurés
non mais parce que les outils sont mal
faits bon mais c'est un moment donné on
peut plus travailler dans ces conditions
là c'est à dire si aucun outil ne
satisfait si aucun effet mesurable et
que on n'en comprend pas les effets un
moment donné faut peut-être projet telle
hypothèse nul enfin il faut peut-être
accepter l'hypothèse nul plutôt rejeté
l'hypothèse que ces difficultés quoi
donc là dessus sur les probabilités
une fois qu'ils disaient que envoya la
plupart des gens en fait ya trois types
de probité il ya 0% 50% et 100% et rien
n'y a rien il n'y a rien au milieu et
est ce qu'on va pouvoir dire est ce
qu'on va pouvoir dire c'est compliqué
c'est à dire que voilà nous quand on
explique par exemple qu'on va faire une
intervention on leur dit il à 0,1 pour
cent de chances que vous fassiez en avc
pendant l'intervention prose 0,1 pour
cent de chance c'est zéro pour ça c'est
fait et moi je leur dis 0,1 pour cent
c'est une chance sur mille
par contre si c'est une chance sur mille
vous c'est 100% votre gueule c'est vous
qui faites 100% l'avc donc il faut le
prendre en considération faut l'admettre
que hope une intervention et sans risque
et tout ça y est ça peut être admis ça
peut être compris mais il faut insister
c'est à dire que si vous déblatérez des
chiffres sans plus de précisions je ne
pense pas que ce soit bien acquis par
contre je pense que si on insiste sur le
fait que un effet secondaire grave qui
survient même rarement des conditions
bien il est grave et il est grave
100% choix là on fait pas 0,1 pour cent
en avc à chaque côté il ya un mec qui a
un mec sur 1000 qui va faire un avc un
vrai en gros voilà féroce et que ça peut
être ça peut être un truc qui va se
faire résoudre très facilement comme ça
peut être un truc grave qui va laisser
des séquelles
on sait pas aller et voilà il ya des
fois moi j'ai les jambes je leur fais
l'échographie ils me disent alors j'ai
les artères du coeur boucher j'ai
vérifié et il veut mais qu'est ce qu'on
va faire si je dis mais pour l'instant
on n'a rien fait non c'est pas donc
quand on sera
on avancera et cette gérer cette
incertitude le fait que l'information
n'est pas disponible immédiatement
donc il n'ya pas de solution voilà et
qu'on aimait tout un tas d'hypothèses
sur ce qu'on pourra trouver c'est
difficile et les gens ont envie qu'on
leur fasse un jeu pas une espèce de
planning général de ce qui va se passer
en fonction des différentes hypothèses
et c'est compliqué je ne sais pas ce
qu'il ya sur leur coronaire je vais pas
leur dire alors si il a rien sur les
coroners on va faire ça 5,6 puis s'il ya
quelque chose à faire ça ça et ça
essentiel de lésions à faire ça ça et ça
et s'il y en a six et demi ici on d'un
syntaxe port à
c'est pas possible on ne peut pas je
peux pas on peut pas de développer
l'ensemble des hypothèses est de toute
façon ce n'est pas satisfaisant pour le
patient c'est déjà dg comprend rien
l'ajout rien de ce qui se passe déjà il
faut juste arriver à faire admettre
l'idée qu'on va aller vérifier les
artères et leur expliquer succinctement
le déroulement
alors les hypothèses derrière ce qu'on
va découvrir ils n'y sont pas ils ont
envie de savoir ils ont envie peut-être
d'avoir cette maîtrise d'avoir la
sensation de maîtrise mais de toute
façon ils sont en encore donc il faut ce
qu'il faut se donner du temps et il ya
beaucoup de travail en médecine en fait
qui n'est pas instantané c'est à dire
l'éducation thérapeutique le temps passé
auprès des gens la pédagogie qu'on va
avoir à les questions auxquelles on va
répondre l'acceptation du traitement
l'acceptation du fait d'être malade
aussi ses trucs ça prend un certain
temps et ça se fait pas en 5 minutes
c'est pas je dis on monsieur monde vous
avez les artères du coeur boucher claque
il a tout compris et tout se passe super
bien et son traitement sera pris à la
perfection et tout va bien dans le
meilleur des mondes c'est pas comme ça
que ça marche
les gens ont besoin du temps pour
comprendre vous à d'accepter il se pose
plein de questions des fois c'est des
questions qui sont pertinentes des fois
c'est des questions qui n'ont aucun
intérêt
des fois ils ont besoin d'avoir volé de
maîtrise absolue alors que dans la
vérité mais c'est impossible
j'ai des patients doit par exemple ils
sortent d'un infarctus ils me disent qu
est ce que j'ai le droit de manger genre
la banane j'ai droit enfin oui oui et le
brocoli
oui aussi et la viande rouge oui enfin
ça c'est plus compliqué que ça et on
leur explique que il faut manger de la
viande rouge mais pas trop mais un peu
mais pas trop mais qui font manger
peut-être plus de légumes peut-être plus
de mach 1 qu'il faut changer un peu son
régime que s'ils mangent de temps en
temps je zappe guémappe ça se passera
mais qu'il faut pas manger la zone kebab
à chaque fois et que c'est pas pour dire
c'est pas blanc ou noir c'est à dire et
pas à mehdi à un aliment méchant ou un
aliment gentil c'est
c'est complexe et c'est des données qui
sont difficiles et les gens ont envie
d'absolu quel sport j'ai le droit de
faire est ce que on leur dit mais on va
éviter les sports que les sports en
charge
oui mais ça j'ai droit ça j'ai pas droit
ça j'ai le droit ça j'ai pas droit c'est
plus compliqué que ça c'est à dire que
vous pouvez faire j'ai pas des sports
qui sont un faible intensité mais le
faire un niveau compétitif tellement
fort que vous allez vous mettre dans le
dur il ya des sports si vous faites de
la compétition mais que vous restez
léger ça reste accessible c'est quelque
chose qui est faisable mais c'est
compliqué entre guillemets d'être très
normatif vis-à-vis des gens et il ya des
gens qui sont très inquiètes de ça c'est
à dire de trouver une nouvelle norme
nouvelle un nouveau truc des ordres en
rouge et enfin ça c'est rouge ça c'est
vers ça c'est rouge sévère et on tolère
assez mal en fait les zones de gris
d'inconfort d'incertitude de on sait pas
trop où est ce que ça va revenir
peut-être est-ce que je pourrais refaire
une poussée c'est possible et c'est
assez complexe et c'est vraiment ce que
gestion de l'incertitude par le grand
public
c'est complexe surtout parce que
l'incertitude est instrumentalisée de
manière générale par les médias 1 pour
créer un climat anxiogène
on ne sait pas quel effet va avoir tel
bidule ils ont sorti des trucs sur le
dioxyde de titane par exemple on sait
pas trop les effets que ça mais on va
faire quelques reportages bien anxiogène
pour dire qu'un a partout et qu'on sait
pas trop ce que est ce que ça fait et du
coup ça à [ __ ] les jetons aux gens et
du coup ben on prend plus utiliser le
dioxyde de titane jeu raison peut-être
pourquoi peut-être ce sera ce sera
sévère peut-être pas mais pour l'instant
ben c'est pas tout quoi on sert est rond
et on aimerait en savoir plus et et je
sais pas les gens peuvent pas ont du mal
à considérer que ben el jour elle ce
truc là étaient globalement radeau
d'appui aujourd'hui on a des doutes et
puis aujourd'hui maintenant on sait que
c'est pas une très bonne idée du coup on
attend d'avoir la preuve pour changer un
petit peu l'habitude sous
attendre tout ça ils aimeraient que je
sais pas qu'on ait une connaissance
absolue et totale de l'ensemble des
molécules des trucs qui nous entoure et
ça me paraît impossible et non
souhaitable de toute façon parce que je
pense que chaque molécule un degré de
toxicité qui est le sien en fonction des
dosages et tout est si vous mettez un
jeu par là si vous mettez aussi vous
mettez un mec que vous remplissez de 8,2
il va mourir alors que l'osce est quand
même important est que s'il a un anneau
g de glyphosate et dans ses urines je ne
suis pas sûr que c'est un effet très
probants sur sa santé donc voila et de
la certitude et je pense qu'il faut
apprendre à mieux la gérer qu'il faut
s'abstenir de discours extrêmement
anxiogènes ou terrifiants pour essayer
de responsabiliser un petit peu mieux la
situation vis-à-vis de son état de santé
voilà pour rester encore sur les eaux du
lac ce pourquoi est ce que tu penses que
les professeurs inventive access qui
sont faux ils sont vraiment mercantile
ou est-ce que l'action dé bonne foi du
professeur anti vaccins c'est très
compliqué je n'ai pas de petit lui parle
en particulier
moi j'en identifie quelques zones tu as
tel professeur joyeux joyeux il est
rentré dans une espèce de doctrine anti
anti médical de manière générale il
vendait des épurateurs quantique
enfin des espèces de mixeur quantique
pour essayer de purifier les légumes
tout ça donc je pense que il est rentré
on bascule en fait dans un domaine qui
est un petit peu en bascule
progressivement fait dans ce genre de
réflexion là c'est à dire c'est pas
quelque chose qui est inné je pense que
c'est un basculement progressif de tout
ça en fait pour parler d'eux
y'a plus générale parce que j'ai pas
envie de citer trop de non j'ai déjà
deux procès ça suffit pour être au très
simple entre guillemets dans quelqu'un
quand vous êtes médecin que vous que
vous rentrez dans la pseudo médecine il
ya j'ai lu un bouquin là dessus qu'ils
étaient peut-être représentatif de la
plupart peut-être pas d'ailleurs mais
qui m'a donné entre nîmes et à un angle
de vue une approche qui pour me
permettre de comprendre faut comprendre
que les médecins généralistes dans les
années on va dire dans les années 80 la
section 50 dans 60 ans quand ils sont
entrés un petit peu sur le marché
ils sont entrés dans un contexte
extrêmement concurrentiel c'est à dire
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de médecins sur
le marché peu de dowland médicale parce
que la population a été pas sûr un
vieillissement aussi important
qu'aujourd'hui et que la demande
médicale et n'était pas aussi forte
parce que les gens sur mehdi khalis tout
maintenant c'est quelque chose d'assez
nouveau mais voilà c'est pour ça que on
est en surcharge parce que la population
n'est pas non plus éduqués à caen
consulter quand on a pas consultés et
que avec des discours anxiogènes bref
voilà mais il y avait peu il y avait
beaucoup de médecins ne te demande et il
sortait de la faculté de médecine sans
avoir fait l'internât maintenant tous
les généralistes sont l'internât plus
généraliste dans une formation
scientifique
ce robuste et universitaire qui est
reconnu il ya des diplômes des
départements universitaires de médecine
générale tout ça mais à l'époque en
sortait généraliste et ça c'est beaucoup
dans la dialectique de mes professeurs
qui m'ont appris à l'époque c'est à dire
que si tu travailles pas bien pourtant
un internat c'est à dire si tu me
faisais pas pour ton examen de 6e année
d'aller finir médecins généralistes dans
la creuse
je ne vais pour les gens de la creuse
mais voilà donc on nous expliquait que
si tu étais nul d'aller finir médecins
généralistes dans la creuse dans le
berry dans le périgord un clermont
ferrand un désolé pour les clermontois
j'ai vécu pendant quatre ans mais bon
alors donc voila c'était on me disait tu
vas finir médecins généralistes dans des
endroits moisi
et ça fait pas plaisir on n'a pas envie
d'être déconsidéré et voilà donc l'image
de la médecine générale c'était un petit
peu épaisse de fonds de tiroirs de gens
qui a eu la flemme de passer l'internât
et ces gens là ont été très
décrédibiliser donc il y à il y avait
deux positions à avoir enfin même trois
soient acceptés sont faites et de dire
mon but je maintiens généraliste je fais
ce que j'ai à faire et puis voilà
et il faisait un petit peu leur beurre
de leur côté se démerder soit ils se
sont vraiment sûrs qualifié sur le plan
sur le plan scientifique
ils sont devenus très très performants
ils ont commencé à étudier beaucoup à
comprendre beaucoup les études
scientifiques et ils se sont positionnés
sur un discours anti expert c'est à dire
à dire que les experts étaient de toute
façon par force soient corrompus soient
manipulés soit voilà qu'il y avait des
forces obscures qui intervenait autour
d'eux et que donc leur conclusion est
erronée et ça c'est les discours qu'on
peut voir certains blogueurs médecin
aujourd'hui qui se sont beaucoup
développées sur cette vague là donc
voilà et il ya ceux qui sont partis dans
une sono médecine pourquoi parce que
l'absurde médecine c'est que ce soit
l'homéopathie la naturopathie et c'est
ça vous permet d'avoir du tarif non
réglementés c'est-à-dire de gagner plus
d'argent
ça vous permet de vous distinguer de la
concurrence donc d'être différent c'est
à dire vous proposer quelque chose de
plus en plus dans les années 80
l'homéopathie été très à la mode c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'elle a été intégré
initialement par l'ordre des médecins
c'est à dire pouvoir contrôler espèce de
dérive cette espèce de vague qui étaient
très importantes y avait vraiment des
espèces de penser newedge qui était
omniprésente à ce moment là et donc
c'est pour ça que l'ordre des médecins
les uns peut intégrer pour pouvoir un
peu de maîtrise et le truc voilà donc
quand vous rentrez là dedans
vous rentrez sur un système qui va vous
permettre de vous distinguer qui va vous
permettre de proposer quelque chose de
plus et qui va vous permettre de gagner
un peu plus d'argent parce qu'il faut
être bassement pécunier voilà seulement
quand vous rentrez dans ce système là
les patients que vous allez voir qu'ils
vont vous consulter
vous allez leur dire exactement ce
qu'ils ont envie c'est à dire que vous
n'allez pas aller contre leur opinion
davantage de ces pseudo médecine c'est
que vous pouvez pas dire un patient non
ne faites pas ça ou non c'est pas une
bonne idée non vous dit toujours oui
vous voulez un médicament j'ai ce qu'il
vous faut vous voulez une solution j'en
ai une vous voulez tel truc j'en ai un
sait on a toujours une solution on a
toujours quelque chose de disponible
mais on a toujours une réponse à
apporter aux gens et ça c'est
extrêmement confortable c'est
extrêmement confortable ne jamais se
retrouver dans une situation
conflictuelle leur inculpation
ça rentre dans quelque chose voilà il
veut l'absolu médecine que vous proposez
vous allez lui donner l'absolution de la
pseudo médecine que vous prescrivez et
de toute façon vous avez une solution
une mono explications à toute chose qui
va satisfaire votre patient et donc ils
vont être satisfaits et tu en as tison
cette réflexion entre rim et de dire à
certains qui sont cyniques je n'ai
entendu il ya pas très longtemps ça il
ya 30% d'effet placebo sur ce genre de
truc bon et bien sûr sur dix patients
les trois qui ont eu l'effet placebo on
ramène dix de plus donc c'est un système
qui s'auto-entretient comme ça c'est à
dire que vous proposer un produit cas
aucun effet secondaire sur lequel
avertir le patient donc ça se passe bien
avec un produit qui a une image
extrêmement positive auprès de votre
patient parce qu'ils vous consulte pour
ça vous consulte parce que justement
vous avez 7 valence là et vous en
attendez un résultat extrêmement positif
après on vous apprend un petit peu à
savoir en jouer à travailler un petit
peu pour essayer de valoriser le produit
tout ça c'est à dire tous la
ritualisation du soin c'est très
important la réactualisation du soin à
dans l'effet placebo de mettre en place
tout un système pour faire en sorte
d'optimiser un petit peu la réussite
d'un traitement que l'on sait inefficace
et au final voilà et je pense pas
vraiment véritablement je ne pense pas
que les mecs qui font à saint
régulièrement nombril mais sache que
c'est de l'effet placebo je pense que à
ce niveau d'implication quand vous
faites ça au long cours de vous même
vous êtes convaincu intimement
intimement que l'on peut pas être
cynique à ce point je pense pas ça
intimement ils sont convaincus qu'ils
font quelque chose de positif pour le
patient qu'ils ont une influence
positive sur le patient même si elle
n'est pas démontrée machin ils sont
persuadés qu'ils répondent à une demande
et que cette demande elle est satisfaite
mais le véritable problème c'est que
éthiquement donner un médicament
inefficace ou entre guillemets jouer sur
cette corde là c'est quelque chose qui
est hyper dangereux parce que mais je
sais pas comment vous dire quand on
amarre tôt
tout devient un clou si vous voulez
c'est et du coup quand on devient ont
primé adeptes de pseudo médecine mais
toutes les situations médicales qu'on va
rencontrer vont plus ou moins soignée
avec cet outil là vous avez l'outil cet
outil pseudo médecine il faut que vous
en servir il faut que vous qui
l'interrompt qu'il soit dans votre froid
de soins et donc vous allez proposer cet
outil là sur des situations de plus en
plus nombreuses tout ça et vous allez
essayer de l'appliquer à d'autres
situations et un moment donné on fera
une connerie parce que s'il ya des
recommandations c'est justement pour
borner et pour dire à tel moment il faut
agir et on retarde entre guillemets
certaines prises en charge et c'est
vraiment je pense que la dynamique on
rentre dedans et puis au fur à mesure
ces pseudos médecine en prennent
d'autres pseudos médecine c'est pas pour
rien non plus que les médecins qui sont
adeptes de pseudo médecine vont adhérer
à une deux trois quatre ans de médecine
supplémentaire c'est à dire c'est pour
ça qu'on voit des médecins homéopathes
acupuncteur mais au thérapeute et c'est
parce que on progresse dans ce truc là
on a la preuve scientifique a plus lieu
d'être
vu qu'elle est déconsidéré vu que on a
des effets on a une valorisation très
positif de tout ça vis-à-vis de notre
patientèle
la preuve scientifique entre lee mais
elle passe un peu à la sppe lui aussi
important que ça aurait pu l'être avant
et où on sera sort bien parce que les
gens sont contents parce qu'on confond
entre guillemets l'efficacité
thérapeutique et la satisfaction client
est effectivement ces gens sont
évidemment satisfait parce que on leur
donne on leur donne ce qu'ils veulent et
on leur dit ce qu'ils veulent entendre
la vraie question et c'est là où je
reviens ce que je disais au début c est
ce que c'est notre rôle en tant que
médecin de dire aux gens ce qu'ils
veulent et de leur donner ce qu'ils
valent ans je pense pas moi je pense que
on est là aussi pour apporter la
contradiction n'est là pour leur dire ça
c'est pas bien ça c'est pas une bonne
idée
les traitements ça se prend comme il
faut ça il faut le faire différemment et
on peut utiliser de tout un tas de
panels de d'interactions et moi j'ai des
patients qui sont beaucoup plus
sensibles à des approches pédagogiques
donc je discute avec eux je leur
explique tout ça j'ai des patients qui
ne sont sensibles à des approches assez
autoritaire c'est à dire que j'ai des
patients peu âgées si on fait de la
pédagogie des explications ils se
sentent je parlais ils n'ont pas
l'habitude ils sont agressés et c'est
pas quelque chose qui est fondamentale
en eux donc ils ont besoin qu'on ait une
approche un peu plus directive un peu
plus voilà où on se pose on dit bon ça
c'est le meilleur traitement donc soit
vous faites ça soit c'est plus la peine
et il ya des fois où il faut refuser de
traiter les gens si on dérive trop c'est
à dire que votre patient vous consulte
par exemple il a un cancer il veut
soigner avec des herbes de provence où
je sais pas quelle bêtise de pseudo
science qui l'aurait l'ua dans un
magazine au machin
si à un moment donné il tombe sur un
médecin qui lui dit oui
laon lui rend pas service ans c'est pas
notre rôle de lui dire oui
notre rôle c'est de lui donner le
meilleur traitement disponibles pour
soigner sa pathologie et de
l'accompagner et de le sortir entre
guillemets d'une croyance qui peut le
mettre en danger
un mec qui va le confrère de le
conforter dans ce genre de croyance d'un
mec est fondamentalement dangereux parce
que il va pas leur mettre dans le chemin
et si ce mec qui consultent leur médecin
généraliste puis franchement il faudrait
prendre les traitements pour le cancer
qui va consulter un autre médecin qui
lui dis franchement traitement contre le
cancer il faut le faire et qu'il va
consulter 4 5 médecins successifs parce
qu'il n'est pas satisfait de la réponse
qu'il entend mais qui l'entend 5 vous la
même chose
un moment donné il va se dire être en
train de déconner vénère fois et il va
peut-être retourner dans le giron il ya
peut-être revenir et peut-être que l'
approche pédagogique de médecins numéro
un cap a fonctionné fonctionnera
peut-être au bout du troisième refus au
bout du troisième non écoutez là je
pense que vous faites de la merde et et
je pense que c'est ça qui me manque
après j'entends le discours de oui mais
bon ces gens là de toute façon ils
trouveront bien ce qu'ils veulent
auprès des charlatans donc autant qu'on
le fasse tout même nom non s'il vient
consulter un médecin il vient consulter
un expert avec un diplôme avec une raie
avec des références quoi un mec qui est
censé maîtriser un peu
si vous consultez un charlatan un mec je
n'ai aucune compétence médicale
j'ai pas qui va sélectionner des têtes
de poulet ou des machins comme ça il va
avoir un charlatan il va voir un mec qui
a pas de diplôme de médecine est ce que
c'est ça qui veut s'ils consultent un
médecin
c'est qu'il veut voir un médecin
peut-être un médecin rigolo d'afro
médecin ouvert d'esprit comme ils disent
mais un médecin c'est ça c'est là où ça
pose problème c'est à dire que à partir
du moment où vous avez refusé
on rentre dans une politique un petit
peu un peu clientéliste un petit peu je
donne un peu ce que ce que vous voulez
on est en est en train de dériver et
c'est ce phénomène l'un entre remy qui
doit être à mon sens dénoncé parce que
les patients ne sont pas responsable du
fait que leur praticien soit plus à jour
sur le plan scientifique ou refuse la
preuve scientifique comme une preuve
suffisante c il est en droit de demander
à ce que le médecin reste un expert et
je trouve je pense à titre personnel que
le fait de pratiquer des pseudos
médecine en tant que médecin c'est à
dire les médecines non éprouvés
scientifiquement et baisse un porte
préjudice à la fois la profession à la
fois aux patients et à la fois à la
pratique qu'on va voir parce que moi
quand je veux soigner un patient entre
guillemets de son insuffisance cardiaque
et que j'ai un praticien alternatifs ou
rigolos qui a arrêté tous les
traitements en disant que c'était ça qui
était responsable de sa déviation de la
colonne vertébrale et que c'est pour ça
que son coeur était malade c'est dur
enfin parce que c'est évidemment un tas
d'énormités mises ensemble tout ça mais
le patient il y croit légitimement cet
arraisonnement d'avoir des passions qui
tous les jours
tous les jours il ya un patient qui a
entendu à la télé que qui a arrêté son
traitement par ce qu'il a lu que qui est
allé sur internet pour vérifier truc qui
a lu la notice et qui a peur d'eux
tous les jours et chez tous les médecins
tous les jours il y à une action d
information qui va avoir lieu et qui va
permettre en prime qui va rendre la
consultation plus difficile que ce soit
madame michu qui a arrêté ses statines
parce que elle a entendu au village que
les statines c'était pas bon et que ces
quinquas et que un bidule afin cancer à
cause des statines après bateau à pour
les remettre les statines avec un avec
ça c'est de la désinformation la madame
michu on peut pas grand chose mais quand
on a une patiente qui a arrêté de
s'alimenter pendant cinq jours parce que
elle a découvert qu'elle avait un cancer
du sein et qui a lu sur qu'elle a vu sur
arte que le gène thérapeutique soigné
bien le cancer ben ça fait chier c'est
lourd quoi etc et c'est tout le temps et
quand on voit que les médicaments sont
arrêtés parce que les patients sont pas
trop médicaments parce qu'il ya une
dialectique en france qui dit que les
médicaments sont par essence toxiques
c'est c'est de la désinformation ça de
toute façon et et tous les jours j'ai
des maîtres qui me dit je suis pas trop
médicaments et je suis pas trop
médicaments ça veut dire je ne vais pas
prendre votre médicament et c'est con
parce qu'ils y viennent pour qu'on les
soigne
moi je sais pas soigné sans médicaments
jeu
voilà j'ai une à la chance en
cardiologie d'avoir une pharmacopée qui
est diverse qui est efficace qui est
intéressante tout ça mais si les baisses
des gens le prennent pas et baisse
marche pas quoi donc c'est vraiment un
problème qui est capital c'est à dire de
l'acceptation de des gens de se faire
prêter de tout ça et c'est éminemment
plus complexe que que tout ça parce que
dans ces phénomènes là entre l'immédiat
il ya tout qui s'entremêlent il ya les
croyances a priori du patient c'est plus
difficile chez un patient qui croient à
priori que le médicament est méchant de
de faire prendre un médicament si en
plus il ya quelqu'un qui vient de
confirmer si en plus il ya quelqu'un qui
essaie d'abuser de sa faiblesse parce
que il a une maladie grave ou quoi et
que à ce moment là ils sont extrêmement
que pour eux enfin un patient cancéreux
moi j'ai une patiente qui m'a dit m'a
dit mais monsieur moi je suis je suis
d'accord avec ce que vous me dites avec
les médicaments tout ça il ya un truc
dont je te parlerai après mais voilà
avec les médicaments et tout ça c'est
vachement important bien des trucs bons
qui sont un petit peu à la marge qui
sont un petit peu sur la médecine tu
vois 10 mai mais si ça à 0,0 à 0,1 pour
cent de chances de marcher moins dans
mon état je prends je peux faire un
cadeau aux arbres ça me pose pas de
problème je peux dépenser 2006 s'emballe
l'important c'est que je survive et il
ya vraiment cette dialectique qui est là
le problème aussi qu'on a c'est que les
gens tu nous expliques que ça pourrait
être complémentaire c'est à dire que les
gens je sais pas il pourrait prendre les
médicaments et en même temps cramé je ne
sais pas quoi faire de l'ensemble sphère
des danses rituelles rituel est toute
simple repas le fait est que l'esprit
humain est limité c'est à dire que
lorsque vous avez en prix mais sur un
plan thérapeutique
admettons vous lorsque tu as 5
injonction par exemple tu dois prendre
concrètement tu dois faire attention à
ce que je suis là ce que tu manges de
salé tu dois faire du sport
voilà c'est des interruptions qui
s'additionnent c'est à dire que le
patient il dit et je dois faire du sport
je manger moins salé
et je dois prendre mes médicaments bon
mécaniquement il va mettre en ordre de
priorité vis-à-vis des injonctions c'est
à dire qu'il va dire notre très
important c'est le médicament
ensuite c'est de manger c'est facile de
manger je le mets en deux et en 3 je
vais mettre le sport est très content la
c3 en fonction et il essaie de les faire
mais toujours par exemple s'il doit
renoncer à une de ses injonctions
ça sera toujours là 3 qui va qu'il va
zapper parce que il dit c'est moins
important
voilà donc si tu prends le même patient
admettons il va le traitement de
référence et médicaments tous attaque et
que derrière tu lui donnes des fonctions
supplémentaires qui elles sont sans
aucun sens c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont
aucune efficacité
c'est à dire tu as lui dire qu'il faut
retirer le lait de son alimentation ou
le gluten c'est très à la mode le grec
ou la viande ou plus qui mangent de
viande ce str et naturopathe ça depuis
manger de viande puis il faut qu'ils
prennent des granules à un horaire
particulier à 16h 19h 22h et puis il
faut qu'il fasse de la chrono nutrition
c'est à dire que l'heure à laquelle et
mange à ce moment là est important
et puis ensuite tu vas lui rajouter
d'autres contraintes c'est à dire qu'il
faut qu'ils jeunes un jour sur 4 pour
pouvoir purifier peu tout ça c'est très
très détox tous appli faut qu'ils
mangent tel truc à la fois que ton
patients et l'a89 injonctions et tu sais
pas con et tu sais pas qu'est laquelle
il va prioriser parce que évidemment
évidemment il ne suivra pas de la faire
jonction c'est parce que sinon après bah
ils mangent que de l'herbe verte au
poison c'est pourri donc il va rater des
âges option est le véritable problème
c'est que s'il a priorisé différemment
c'est à dire si le médicament et les
plants sains ni l'es15 a perdu tu as
perdu sur le plan médical pourtant il a
le médicament qui est prescrit tout ça
mais c'est moins important que d'aller
supprimer le lait que d'aller faire
attention un tel truc que ne pas faire
tel truc que de manger machin est donc
mal il aura plus tendance à oublier has
appelé parce qu il considère pas ça
comme suffisamment important dans le
cadre de l'entretien de sa santé
et c'est là où ça devient problématique
c'est à dire que c'est là où tu touches
le problème de la médecine en comprimés
alternatives et complémentaires c'est
que c'est jamais complémentaire c'est à
dire que il ya aussi un rôle en du
médecin dans la parcimonie des
instructions il faut faire gaffe de pain
abreuver le patient d'injonction parfois
paradoxale c'est à dire que contraire
c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'ils fassent
du sport mais il faut pas qu'ils forcent
trop un mec il comprend plus tu vois et
trois gardes il fait c'est à dire je
suis dispo recommande donc voilà il faut
minimiser les injonctions c'est-à-dire
recentrer sur l'essentiel et lui dire ça
franchement vous cassez pas le cul avec
ça sert à rien
voilà donc moi ma patiente quand je lui
ai dit le régime cétogène et le jeune
thérapeutique
vous pouvez le mettre à la lourde ça
sert à rien elle était contente c'est
lourd c'est super lourd tu vas pas
manger tel alimente pas faire tel truc
tu pas ma rachat il faut que tu manges
plein de plein de protéines c'est super
casse couilles c'est super casse
couilles et du coup voilà donc elle a pu
se concentrer sur des trucs et c'est une
charge mentale qui est enlevé et je
pense que entre l'image c'est pas je
suis pas sûr que ce soit théoriser mais
ce phénomène entre guillemets de
hiérarchisation des injonctions je pense
qu'il est fondamental aussi dans notre
prise en charge parce que les gens
mécaniquement lorsqu'ils doivent faire
attention à leur santé ils vont toujours
faire cette espèce d'ordre de priorité
inconscient et dire ça c'est vraiment
ultra important ça ça l'est moins
ça c'est les beaucoup moins et sa
mâchoire et sas a pu passer à l'as est
trop d'injonction de toute façon il y en
a qui seront appelés ce que c'est et
voilà un aspect humain il est limité on
peut pas suivre 25,1 de l'action à moins
d'avoir un tableau et les marques et
toutes les biffer à chaque fois mais bon
voilà les gens sont pas comme ça la
plupart
ça me paraît difficile et il ya vraiment
tout ça à mon avis qui rentrent en ligne
de compte et qui rencontre nîmes et la
médecine complémentaire difficile il ya
aussi l'acceptation de la réalité
scientifique les mecs nous disent race
va c'est pas parce que parce que c'est
pas très scientifique que ça va pas mais
justement c'est super important
si le scientifique a plus aucune
importance il ya aucune de nos
recommandations qui tient aucune on peut
faire n'importe quoi je peux donner du
champagne à mes gens qui sont
hypertendus tout va bien quoi et c'est
pas vrai c'est dans la vraie vie tu
donnes des médicaments tu suis un
phénomène de recommandation tu te fie
aux expérimentations qui ont été faites
par d'autres gens que toi qui ont été
confirmés et tu donnes le meilleur
traitement disponible aujourd'hui
traitement qui va peut-être révolu
peut-être dans deux ans ce sera plus le
traitement de référence mais c'est pas
grave très grave parce que à ce moment
là c'était le meilleur traitement
disponibles des personnes il ya personne
des années 80 qui est fâché parce qu'ils
ont eu un traitement des années 80 qui a
été et pas celui qui a été développé en
2016 en voilà c'est logique mais c'est
quelque chose dans l'acceptation entre
limay de de comment ça s'appelle ans
j'ai perdu mon nom de ce qu'on peut pas
maîtriser de il faut accepter qu'il y
ait des trucs qu'on peut pas maîtriser
qui est des trucs qu'on va découvrir des
trucs qui nous feront pas plaisir des
trucs qui nous feront plaisir et cette
gestion d'incertitude
elle est de plus en plus complexes il ya
des tas de gens qu'il est noir disant ah
comment ça se fait qu'on découvre que
maintenant que tel truc est toxique ce
que tu disais sur les nombreuses
injonctions et le manque de priorisation
c'est un truc que tu ici à part dans
votre beau même si par exemple on prenne
des changements climatiques
souvent les gens insistent sur des trucs
qui sont très minimes par rapport aux
prêts du changement climatique
donc par exemple j'ai vu une vidéo
récemment jamais trop bien pour ceux que
le voir sur l'impact environnemental de
manger une banane qui vient qui a été
transporté par avion
l'impact environnemental de manger sa
banane en fait beaucoup beaucoup moins
donc tu par exemple arrêter de manger
moins de viande dans d'autres choses qui
sont beaucoup plus prioritaires en
termes de changements climatiques et
c'est important le sommant de prioriser
et finalement à ce qu'on parle enfin de
c'était que ce transport la banane etc
on insiste beaucoup sur ça en fait ça
revient à faire de la pollution
informationnelle les césar j'ai
l'information son père il y à il ya
beaucoup il ya beaucoup c'est une des
stratégies des pseudos médecine et c'est
aussi une des stratégies des
multinationales qui font qu'ils
travaillent dans la pollution de toute
façon si vous si vous submerger la
population de messages pour lutter
contre la pollution qui sont des
messages entre guillemets anodin c'est à
dire le fait pipi dans la douche et tout
ça que vous mobiliser je suis pas
quelqu'un de 3 influenceurs pour essayer
de lancer ce message là et que vous
refusez en fait est que vous mettez au
milieu ouais on va faire des efforts sur
la production textile et tout ça en fait
les gens ils vont voir qu'à 25 à 30 35
injonction différentes et au final les
injonctions principal qui est il
faudrait quand même que les entreprises
les plus polluantes et une attitude
raisonnée et raisonnable vis-à-vis de
tout ça et commence à agir un petit peu
plus green mais parce que c'est ça on
brille mais qui polluent le plus c'est
pas toi qui t'es trompé de poubelles
pour pourra pourra du verre ou du
plastique ce qui pollue véritablement
c'est les industries à paître
pétrolifères c'est tout ça c'est
vraiment important et s'il ya pas de
politique entre rim et répressive ou
fortement incitative pour limiter à
cette espèce de production à tout va
mais ça sert à rien de pisser dans la
douche façon tout va être cramé donc
voilà donc où ouais je pense que il ya
beaucoup cette pollution a fermé
informationnelle et en prix mais lorsque
vous avez les pseudos médecine qui ont
pignon sur cours dans tous les magazines
féminins dans tous les magazines qui ont
vaguement rapport à la santé je parle
pas du magazine de la santé de france 5
qui est à peu près correct parce qu'ils
les intervenants bas de six ans souvent
mais vous avez tout un tas de magazines
un petit peu à je sais pas tu vois
magazine un petit peu people tout ça
quand une rubrique santé et qui vous
expliquent que la la qu'est-ce que je
peux faire pour me redresser dissolution
pour lutter contre le mal de dos et que
dans les 10 solutions vocales et 5,6
pseudo médecine dedans comment comment
est ce que le patient feltri moment
esquissés çà c'est caca ça c'est pas
kaka et c'est à ce niveau là où on
aimerait que l'état arrive à prioriser
et dix bombes et ça franchement c'est de
la merde
et ça c'est intéressant et et qu'on
n'est pas ces messages entre guillemets
qui pollue tout ça parce que
effectivement dire à quelqu'un on vas tu
pourrais faire un peu d'ostéopathie ça
mange pas de pain en ouest
ça mange pas de pain mais bon le premier
traitement du mal de dos et de continuer
de rester en activité quoi et lorsque
vous donnez il faudra voir l'ostéopathe
et le chiropracteur et le bidule et
machins et un radiesthésiste et mes
couilles mais les patients ils sont là
ils font bon ben écoute est resté actif
c'est quand même presque où il ya un an
je vais le mettre en neuf et est par
contre aller voir tel ou tel
professionnel de santé qui va me
délester de 75 balle pourquoi pas après
tout parce que c'est une solution
consommables et c'est toujours plus
acceptable c'est à dire quand on regarde
les gens et qu'on leur dit comment
lutter contre le cancer du côlon soit tu
as tu mange équilibré tout la vie soit
utilise un jus de courgettes détox qui
va te détoxifier enlever toutes les
toxines
c'est quand même vachement plus sympa le
jus de courgettes détox on est d'accord
puisse intégrer ça déculpabilise
franchement c'est qu'elles seront bien
de manger de manger régulièrement à des
trucs sain et tout franchement j'ai pas
envie hein personne n'a envie mais cette
solution là et quand même beaucoup plus
sexy beaucoup plus avenant tout ça enfin
et c'est mais ça marche pas et la vérité
c'est que ça marche pas et
c'est inadmissible que ce soit vendu
comme un équivalent ou comme quelque
chose comme une alternative acceptable
ce n'est pas une alternative acceptable
un mec qui mangent n'importe quoi c'est
un mec qui va mourir c'est à la fin
voilà c'est pas cool
si votre papa y meurent parce que lille
mans il ment il mangeait que du caca et
bien vous serez pas content du mec qui
leur a recommandé de faire des cure de
détox qui servent en rien quoi c'est moi
c'est celle là dessus en tri mais enfin
c c'est pour ça que on s'est positionné
pour lutter contre eur les pseudo
science de manière générale parce que je
pense que cette perception erronée du
monde et cette perception du fait
scientifique comme étant un fait que en
prime une opinion comme une autre c'est
ce qu'on a pu voir sur le
climato-scepticisme c'est quelque chose
d'éminemment dangereux que ce soit en
médecine
que ce soit en climatologie ou en
sciences en mathématiques ou en physique
quoi c'est je pense que faire émerger
une espèce de réalité alternative ou
encore les faits pour leur faire dire ce
qu'on a envie en fonction de notre
obédience politique c'est inquiétant
quoi ça fait pas plaisir que ce soit de
droite comme de gauche
que ce soit d'un côté le lobby bio ultra
pure où il faut manger que des aliments
comme ci comme ça et que sinon c'est pas
bien et qui alimente un autre type
d'industrie ou à un lobby de droite qui
considère que le ce qu'on me dit en
médecine c'est que des injonctions qui
atteignent à la liberté et que les gens
ont le droit de manger n'importe quoi et
que c'est quand même bien des conneries
de limiter à deux mètres en marquage
nutri score à chercher les gens pour
qu'ils puissent identifier les aliments
les plus caloriques
ça c'est de l'aube il a entre rim et je
pense qu'ils sont problématiques et je
pense et c'est ce que c'est là dessus
que je terminerais qu'on doit avoir un
positionnement beaucoup plus politique
c'est à dire que
mais la défense de la rationalité en
fait elle se fait pas tout seul et si on
n'existe pas sur le champ politique
c'est à dire s'il ya pas d âge en un
système rationnel pour défendre sa pour
s'opposer vivement pour lutter contre
bas à la fin ce qui existe sur le champ
politique mais c'est pas nous et au
final ceux qui ceux qui vont raconter de
la merde
la baisse et pas nous donc moi je
préfère que nous on existe sur le champ
politique comme une force comme un lobby
comme une force d' influence importante
parce que on défend un fait scientifique
on défend des choses qui sont réelles en
prime et en défenseur de quelque chose
qui est intéressant est que si on laisse
cette place à des gens mais qui font du
pognon là dessus ou qui ont tout intérêt
à ce que le fait scientifique n'émerge
pas et on se retrouve dans une dans une
société à la trump et c'est parce que je
veux quoi donc ça me permettra une
transition vers le fait que tu aies
président du collectif fait que m hélas
hélas si tu veux présenter un peu le
collectif fait m c'est pas trés trés
c'est pas très compliqué on a fait une
tribune dans le figaro là pour dire que
bert en médecine c'est quand même
vachement bien ne pas faire de
charlatanisme et qu'il ya certaines
spécialités en prime est reconnu par
l'ordre des médecins reconnus par le
ministère de la santé en travers de
remboursement etc qui sont des pseudos
médecine c'est à dire qu'en jamais fait
la preuve de leur efficacité et notre
objectif c'était de faire en sorte
qu'elles retrouvent leur place de pseudo
médecine c'est à dire qu'elle perde
cette légitimité qui n'est pas qu'il
aurait pendu à la fois sur le plan
universitaire parce que c'est enseigner
à l'université à la fois sur le plan du
remboursement parce que c'est remboursé
est donc reconnu d'une manière générale
par la sécurité sociale
et cette reconnaissance par l'ordre des
médecins parce que ça contrevient à
plusieurs articles de notre code de
déontologie dont un article qui dit
qu'on doit exercer notre métier selon
les données acquises de la science
donc pratiquer une sono médecine c'est à
dire quelque chose qui est en marge du
fessier anti fiq est respectée demandez
aux affaires cette consigne
déontologique c'est complètement
impossible donc l'idée c'était de dire
ben écoutez si vous voulez faire de la
pseudo médecine vous le faites mais pas
en votre titre de médecin
prenez un cabinet ailleurs et voilà et
quand vous faites de la médecine ou fait
de la médecine c'est à dire quelque
chose qui est basée sur la science et
notre proposition c'était d'avoir une
proposition qui était en accord avec les
recommandations de médecine générale
c'était de rentrer dans une logique plus
de des prescriptions c'est-à-dire de
prescrire moins et de prescrire mieux de
réfléchir à l'ensemble de notre donne
aux prescriptions c'est à dire sur
certains médicaments les réévaluer
fréquemment est limitée par exemple à la
prescription d'anxiolytiques et de
psychotropes c'est à dire de dire au
bout de six semaines où je connais pas
les dates mais de huit semaines
d'évaluer est ce que on est à l'objectif
est de repasser sur autre chose de
refaire le point fréquemment de proposer
une médecine humaine même s'il est basé
sur la science c'est à dire de remplacer
la prescription systématique d'un
granules par une écoute attentive par de
la bienveillance par est ce que les gens
viennent rechercher en fait j'ai cherché
ces médecins homéopathes par exemple
c'est à dire une écoute et là dedans
passé avec eux qui soit satisfaisant
parce que il ya un fait en médecine
c'est que avec la demande qui s'est
accrue et le fait que même les cabinets
sont pris d'assaut
on a de moins en moins de temps à
accorder aux patients si on veut pas
avoir des délits catastrophique par
exemple moi je prends une demi-heure par
patient tu vois après j'ai trois mois de
délai en la radiologie et c'est dur tu
vois enfin je suis pas encore installé
c'est important de le dire
les collègues là ils ont des rendez vous
en juillet donc c'est je précise qu'on
est au mois de mai pour ce qui
pour ceux qui disent ça plutôt donc
c'est compliqué en garde biologie où on
doit gérer quand même un minimum
d'urgence en ophtalmo il ya un an le
délai tout ça ça devient complexe et
donc on a de moins en moins de temps
mécaniquement à passer avec les patients
et on se concentre sur l'important c'est
à dire sur la médecine et la pédagogie
on se dit bah ouais il faudrait que
quelqu'un le fasse mais franchement la
minute c'est chou quoi voilà donc on
essaie de se dire on va essayer de
prendre peut-être plus de temps avec les
patients pour les sortir un peu de ce
carcan là et pour essayer de satisfaire
un petit peu à la demande me demande qui
est difficile à satisfaire
parce que ben a de plus en plus de gens
qui demandent des airs de moins en moins
de temps à leur accorder
et les gens sont pas contents quand on
passe passe et part avec eux mais ils
sont pas non plus content quand ils
doivent attendre plusieurs jours pour
voir leur médecin généraliste ou
plusieurs mois pour voir un spécialiste
donc donc c'est complexe donc nous notre
idée c'était un petit peu ça on a posé
une tribune dans le figaro pour dire que
quand même c'était pas coulé pour
informer le grand public que aujourd'hui
il ya des pseudos médecine qui sont
reconnus rembourser alors qu'elles n'ont
pas fait leurs preuves scientifiques ce
qui était attestée par l'académie de
médecine et l'académie européenne des
sciences
donc on était très content on s'est
présenté sur plusieurs tableaux plateaux
télé et on a expliqué un petit peu le
phénomène
on était très mal reçu au début un peu
mieux a par la suite quand les
journalistes on commençait vraiment à
s'intéresser au sujet a créé des sujets
de fond et à comprendre qu'il y avait
vraiment un problème de fond c'est à
dire que le développement de ces pseudo
médecine comme étant des alternatives
fiables
c'était peut-être pas si frais est
évident que ça et par la suite on a pris
une volée de plainte
l'ensemble des signataires identifiables
ont reçu une plainte du syndicat désobéi
au pacte entre guillemets qui ont
défendu leur business que je les
comprends comme je vous ai dit je
comprends aussi j'ai ce mec qu'on combat
zeller vie à faire de l'homéopathie
pendant 35 ans et aujourd'hui on leur
dit que ben c'est quand même pas
terrible
ils sont pas contents ils se défendent
donc je l'entende
même si j'ai pris deux plaintes dans la
tronche à suez là
je l'entends mais je pense que ça valait
le coup d'avoir un positionnement clair
franc et honnête du coup on s'est
retrouvé avec ses 70 plaintes il a fallu
les gérer ducournau collectif s'est
constitué en association est une
association qui essaye de s'informer
auprès du grand public sur des pratiques
sur la médecine sur les pseudos médecine
en général
l'objectif premier de l'association
c'est d'être un recours auprès des
journalistes c'est à dire quand les
journalistes ont une question à poser
sur le plan médical ils ont une réponse
scientifique c'est à dire que on leur
donne on leur donne l'information bon
d'essayer de le faire vite parce que des
fois ils ont aidé les siens mais on est
disponible pour discuter avec de données
qui sont éprouvés par la science de
recommandations et on va pas rentrer
dans une démarche en prime mercantile
c'est à dire que quand un médecin
s'exprime dans les médias en général
c'est qu'il a un bouquin à vendre on n'a
pas de bouquins à vendre voilà c'est
tout on est là on leur donne une info
ils veulent savoir si la sève de bouleau
par exemple est un médicament
intéressant on leur répond qu'on n'a pas
de données à ce sujet là et voilà ils
sont ça leur permet de répondre ou si on
a des données sur tel père tel pseudo
médecine aussi tel truc et les gîtes ou
pas et on essaye de leur donner les
armes pour pouvoir comprendre pour
pouvoir identifier tout ça et je pense
que c'est intéressant c'est une démarche
qui a ses vertus et ça leur permet de
faire des papiers qui sont plus qu'ali
et nous ça nous permet en tant que
médecin d'être plus peinard parce que si
à moins de ne pas piller dégueulasse ou
de deux reportages stupide hébert on est
quand même plus tranquille dans nos
cabinets en fait et on a moins la
jonction bizarre un type
je sais pas prescrits mais vous
prescrivez mois des fleurs de bach pour
mon infarctus
parce que voilà donc pour viser un
objectif dans le collectif
le dernier comptage je serais plutôt
dire dernier constat je pense qu'on doit
être 200 ou 300 quelque chose comme ça
donc fin 200 300 qui ont cotisé et en
termes de sympathisants on est plus à
2000 3000 mai mais voilà ouais ouais il
ya un petit peu de monde c'est quelque
chose qui mobilise un peu mais surtout
ben on a créé un petit réseau pour
pouvoir interagir pouvoir communiquer
quand on voit on essaye avec la page du
collectif sur les réseaux sociaux
d'intervenir quand on voit avec il ya un
média un petit peu influent qui sort une
énorme connerie on essaie d'expliquer
que pas exactement les jt de donner
quelques armes très simple pour pouvoir
répondre à tout ça on essaye de
déconstruire certaines idées reçues on
essaie de communiquer vis-à-vis de tout
ça et puis bon soutient aussi les mecs
qui ont pris des plaintes auprès de
l'ordre des médecins pour éviter qu'ils
se fassent radier quoi parce que ce
serait dommage beaucoup de plaintes
comme ça 70 à peu près donc ouais ça
occupe un petit peu puis bon c'est les
médecins si tu veux qu'ils font leur
travail comme il faut qui essaye de se
baser sur les recommandations qui font
un aphte propre qui travaillent un petit
peu dans la recherche y aller dm clp hb
et les chefs de service et les
professeurs enfin il ya de tout quoi et
ces ultimes mans vexant en fait de dire
j'ai défendu le fait scientifique et je
suis poursuivi pour ça c'est quand même
dommage c'est comme si toi tu fais pas
tu dis franchement la recherche en
mathématiques c'est vachement cool et
qu'il y avait un groupe je sais pas de
deux mathématiciens alternatif qui
venait de tomber sur la gueule et porté
plainte contre eux tu voies ferrées
je dirais c'est quand même à pas sympa
quoi ouais ça va être facile
il est essentiellement docteur tous
docteur alors du touch médecin oui mais
du coup vous avez quand même c'est pas
parce que je mets une seule à prendre
pas mal de temps de jeu
oui oui même au début c'était un petit
peu compliqué c'était de regrouper les
gens de leur donner les informations
juridiques parce que ben on n'a jamais
été poursuivi à l'ordre pour l'immense
majorité d'entre nous donc on savait pas
trop comment faire on savait pas trop
comment gérer et puis voilà mais par
contre là où cela est intéressant c'est
qu'effectivement quand les mecs porte
plainte et s'en vante auprès de
différents médias ça a créé un espèce de
tweet clash buzz où il fallait la
réponse
il fallait faire le claj tout ça et on
fait ça nous a donné une tribune en fait
le plus de plus forte c'est à dire que
dans l été obligés de nous donner la
parole et quand on parlait mais c'est
intéressant parce qu'on présentait mais
une médecine qui parle aux gens c'est à
dire ce que fait le médecin généraliste
de base c'est à dire écoutez les jambes
parce que la plupart des gens
considèrent pas que leur généraliste est
un gros con qui les écoutent pas la
plupart ont une affection profonde
travaille avec lui c'est quelqu'un qui
intervient c'est quelqu'un qui a su se
mettre en opposition avec eux les
emmerder quand il fumait pour qu'ils
arrêtent de fumer les emmerder parce
qu'ils prennent pas leur traitement et
et avoir une approche peut-être voilà
pour leur expliquer tout ça et c'est
quelque chose qui les a peut-être aidé
un moment donné qui sait quelque chose
voilà le médecin généraliste a quand
même une place très importante et je
pense qu'au travers des discours qu'on a
pu avoir des discussions qu'on a pu
avoir
ils ont retrouvé leur médecin
généraliste en quelqu'un de pragmatique
mais quelqu'un qui est à l' écoute qui
est empathique et tout ça et qu'en face
ils sont tombés sur des jambes mais qui
était un petit peu un petit peu mystique
quoi et je crois qu'ils sont plus
reconnues dans notre discours que
de parcimonie de recours quand même plus
précautionneux aux médicaments de
questionnements de notre rapport notre
rapport au corps et au patient plutôt
que de dire oh là là mais l'eau se
souvient et nos médicaments sont
merveilleux je crois que ça a plus
porter et je pense que c'est important
tu vois que ce discours est à exister
d'une manière ou d'une autre c'est à
dire qu'on ait pu dire à des heures de
grande écoute que le médecin généraliste
est aussi quelqu'un qui intervient que
le médecin généraliste lui aussi à une
vision globale du patient parce que ça
c'est très médecines alternatives le
médecin c'est un nul qui a pas la vision
globale du patient alors que nous les
alternatifs
on voit la vision globale du patient on
considère pas le patient comme un jambon
qui considère son patient comme un
jambon comme comme médecin fin c'est
complètement con quoi c'est juste
on essaie de gérer du mieux qu'on peut
quoi et des fois on répond pas à toutes
les toutes les injonctions de nos
patients dont c'est leur dire non on
sait leur dire oui quand il faut en sait
manier le chaud et le froid pour essayer
de de les soigner le mieux possible et
on fait ce qu'on peut et est ce qu on a
quoi est-ce que j'ai des projets soumis
aux équipes des projets au sein du
collectif
déjà nous on a on a travaillé beaucoup
sur ce qu'on appelle le fake mais doit
être c'est à dire enfin pas me fait mal
aux maîtres mais le fait québec c'est à
dire un espèce d'index sur lequel on
peut consulter différents pseudos
médecine et avoir une explication
lisible à accessible de ski une pseudo
médecine ou pas c'est compliqué à faire
parce que les pseudo médecine sont prêts
imaginative et dès qu un terme dès
qu'une dénomination est passée un peu en
désuétude ou qu' on en a un peu mal
parlé dans les hauts plateaux
il change un tout petit peu la
dénomination et change un petit peu la
broche et ils font quelque chose qui est
relativement similaire mais un peu en
différents et en fait les données des
noeuds les dénominations qui se donne
ont assez peu de sens quoi enfin c'est à
dire que si tu t'es tu ta l'acupuncture
qui par un petit peu à un petit peu à la
dérive tu dois tu l'appelles un petit
peu différemment ou tu vas être
conscient que tu vas te concentrer sur
les oreilles et taxes advient de leurs
et culotté rapide c'est mieux ou taxe ça
s'appelle de la luxopuncture c'est un
petit peu différent mais le principe est
à peu près le même
donc voila et même si tu va débloquer
l'acupuncture on va te dire ouais mais
là c'est pas pareil parce que c'est un
peu différent
es tu passes un petit peu comme ça et il
ya tout le temps de plus ou moins de
choses donc c'est entre guillemets pour
donner un ordre d'idée de tout ça de sa
de connaître un petit peu l'existant et
les références bibliographiques qui nous
amène à considérer que ça c'est plutôt
peut prouver à prouver ou que ses
limites terre il ya aussi une facilité
entre guillemets chez les pseudos
médecine c'est plus fourbe que ça c'est
à dire que et ça se déguise la dirige
j'utilise un fond un peu vrai un peu
véridique c'est à dire quelque chose qui
s'appuie sur des données scientifiques
éprouvées et ils font ce que j'appelle
l'extension de garantie
c'est à dire que par exemple
l'ostéopathie sur un plan scientifique
sur ce qui a été étudiée à un intérêt
classe de classe 2 à c'est-à-dire un
intérêt probable dans le cadre des
lombalgies chroniques avec un effet qui
est considéré comme étant faible ou très
modéré donc ça marche un peu sur les
lombalgies parce qu'il ya un effet
massage parce qu'il ya tout ça et que
c'est positif chez les gens très bien
seulement l'ostéopathe ne fait pas que
ça parce que bell ostéopathe il a besoin
de manger
il peut pas faire que des douloureux du
dos chroniques donc ils font des
extensions de garantie il fonde la
domine ali fondu crânien il fond du trou
alors que ça ça n'a jamais montré une
quelconque efficacité mais voilà c'est
l'extension de garantie ce pareil pour
l'hypnose l'hypnose c'est très
intéressant
en complément d'une anesthésie locale
pour accompagner certaines personnes
c'est super c'est vachement bien
l'hypnose mais ça permet pas d'arrêter
de fumer
ça permet pas de faire des tas de trucs
ça permet pas de truc qui a rien qui
démontrait vis-à-vis de des
psychothérapies arrion supérieur
vis-à-vis de l'hypnose donc il ya ce
problème là aussi de d'avoir un truc qui
est vaguement les gîtes sur certaines
indications et comme il est vaguement
les gîtes sur deux ou trois indications
de dire à baisser les gîtes donc ça va
ça marche surtout et c'est ça qui est
problématique
il ya aussi beaucoup l'explication
holistique c'est à dire c'est ce que
font nos amis naturopathe c'est tout et
l'alimentation d'un cancer c'est
l'alimentation vous avez nez qui coule
c'est l'alimentation vous avez tel truc
c'est l'alimentation
et il ya aussi ceux qui se basent entre
guillemets sur des pathologies
existantes et qui font des extended cut
c'est à dire des versions améliorées
d'une pathologie existantes pour faire
en sorte que ça rentre dans un cadre
nosologique alternatif et que ce soit
soigné ça je vais me faire fumer pour ça
parce que voilà mais il ya plusieurs par
exemple maladie qui existe qui ont des
stades primaire secondaire tertiaire
voulu inventer un stade chronique et à
ce moment là vous pouvez prendre des
patients qui ont des pathologies entre
limiers diverses et multiples 1 et des
pathologies qu'on appelle fonctionnel
c'est à dire des gens qui ont des
fatigues chroniques une fatigabilité
musculaire que des trucs qui sont pas
mesurables c'est à dire que des trucs
que tu peux pas avoir ni voir au scanner
ni voir sur le plan biologique qui sont
prêts très subjectif en fait tu les
regroupe dans un espèce de cadres
nosologique et tu leur donnes ça c'est
ce qu'ils font avec les syndrome
d'ehlers danlos c'est à dire que le lr
dans lost une pathologie qui existe qui
est une pathologie génétique des tissus
conjonctifs
et il ya des parties siens alternatifs
qui ont utilisé entre rim et une grille
qui te permet d'inclure un maximum de
patients et qui nous font des syndrome
d'ehlers danlos chroniques qui sont en
fait des gens qui sont fatigués
chronique tout ça à qui on trouve un
cadre nosologique c'est à dire qui on
trouve une explication de l'art de
l'ensemble de leurs symptômes et qui au
final vont s'accrocher à ce diagnostic
parce qu'ils leur donnent un statut
parce qu'ils leur donnent accès à une
reconnaissance quelle qu'elle soit et
qui vont devenir les défenseurs et qui
vont être eux mêmes leurs propres
bourreaux
on a ça dans le lr dans l'os comme je
t'ai dit mais tu as ça dans tout ce qui
est fibromyalgie dans tout ce qui est
syndrome de fatigue chronique dans
myofasciite dans la myofasciite à
macrophages ça c'est la maladie entre
guillemets de notre ami le professeur
gherardi c'est à dire que la vaccination
laisse une cicatrice alumine hic quand
tu as gect donc il ya des résidus
d'aluminium dans son tissu musculaire
qui restent là et il met 100 en relation
avec un espèce de syndrome de fatigue
chronique mal étiquetés et ils appellent
ça aille mieux facilite à macrophages et
claque ça devient nouvelles maladies
reconnues par personne à part par les
malades et on dit ouais c'est la
vaccination qui m'a rendu malade et du
coup c'est pour ça je suis donc dans
fatigué que je double temps de priest
que c'est compliqué la vie et que je
peux plus faire seul effort et voilà et
ces gens là on leur propose pas une
solution qui a adapté parce que la
solution qui a adapté
souvent c'est un accompagnement
psychologique c'est tout ça mais il ya
aussi dans ces gens là des gens qui
refusent à l'étiquetage 6 de leur
pathologie et ça s'est compliqué ma
passion psy qui refuse qu'on dise qu'il
est psy il va trouver toutes les
alternatives possibles pour se trouver
une cause organique est de ce fait il va
se détourner des traitements qui sont
efficaces pour lui on retrouve ça aussi
dans le lane chronique dans le lem
chronique c'est une communauté qui est
extrêmement virulente extrêmement
agressive donc j'évite de me les mettre
à dos
parce que menaces de mort régulièrement
donc c'est compliqué mais ça rentre dans
ce cadre là c'est à dire un extended cut
d'une pathologie qu'on connaît on
connait pas ultra bien c'est à dire que
le live c'est pas non plus extrêmement
étudié extrêmement machin mais qui est
quand même connu et pour lequel on ils
vont leur maître par exemple des
semaines des mois d'antibiotiques et ils
vont les réévaluer par la suite voilà et
ses jambes mais ils sont pris en charge
par des pseudo thérapeutes qui sont
bienveillants avec eux et ça leur fait
du bien c'est sûr mais ça l'est souhaite
pas à ce que le problème de fond il est
toujours là quoi donc c'est les pseudos
médecine elles prennent différentes
formes différentes visage c'est
compliqué de les dénoncer parce que il
ya de la thune derrière parce qu'il ya
des gens qui en profite parce qu'il ya
des médecins qui abusent de leur statut
pour essayer de donner une légitimité à
tout ça et c'est un combat de tous les
jours et on n'a pas d'argent et du coup
c'est plus ou moins c'est moins simple
pour nous que pour eux quoi qu'est-ce
qui vous montrent efficaces une
reconnaissance institutionnelle tout
simplement les enfants c'est à dire que
l'ordre des médecins si tu veux quand
dans leur situation
mais comme je les ai déjà expliqué à
certains l'ordre des médecins tout le
monde est assez d'accord par exemple sur
l'homme et sur l'homéopathie
tout le monde est assez d'accord pour
dire que ça n'a aucune efficacité
scientifique
il n'y a pas grand monde qui vient
contester ça même les homéopathes et
c'est pas même la campagne imprimée à
mon sommet aux manchois vous regarderez
bien à aucun moment il n'a marqué que le
médicament est efficace
aucun moment parce que s'ils peuvent pas
le dire
dire ce que les gens sont contents que
laisse à chaumont servent beaucoup etc
mais il n'y a pas marqué il n'y a pas on
ne dit pas que le médicament est
efficace donc c'est pas très contestée
l'inefficacité de lomé au c'est quelque
chose qui est avisée mais vous avez
entre eux 3000 à 5000 médecins qui sont
homéopathe certains exercices exclusif
si vous les reconnaissez plus qu'est ce
qu'ils font ces mecs il ya mon ami
médecin va ces premiers extraits mis sur
pied ce 5000 déclaré homéopathe c'est à
dire qu'il donne qui ont dû le marquer
sur leurs plaques après qui sont en
exercice exclusif je pense pas qu'il y
en ait beaucoup beaucoup
donc voila mais il y en a et ces mecs là
vouloir retirer cette valence
homéopathique qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
ont fait 35 ans qui font en 30 ans 35
ans qui font plus de médecine
qu'est ce qu'ils deviennent et en plus
ils exercent un truc qui est important
en terme de démographie médicale c'est
qu'ils font un maillage territorial
ils font peut-être pas de la médecine
evidence based c'est à dire une médecine
près scientifique mais ils ont un
maillage territorial c'est à dire qu'ils
sont dans certaines zones qui s'y sont
pas la baie deviendraient des déserts
médicaux
donc l'ordre des médecins est un peu
coincé avec ces mecs là parce que ils
vont pas les jeter
mais en même temps c'est pas très bien
non plus ils le savent ils le savent
aussi bien que nous donc c'est complexe
c'est pas ça peut pas être tout blanc
peut pas les éradiquer ces gens là donc
on aimerait que la reconnaissance
qu'elle y soit plus c'est à dire qu'ils
fassent ça un petit peu dans leur coin
quoi mais la réalité du terrain c'est
aussi ça c'est à dire que le manque de
médecins et que c'est quand même les
médecins
il essaie d'avoir des relations avec pas
avec l'inserm balles d'autres
discussions avec nous on a essayé
d'avoir comme ceux dits non l'objectif
il est plus politique c'est à dire que
le propos c'est pas d'influencer les
instituts scientifiques instituts
scientifiques nous fournissent la
matière première c'est à dire les
résultats et nous on est là pour faire
la diffusion sur le plan politique et
sur le plan journalistique et du grand
public donc que l'inserm face de la
production scientifique c'est très bien
le véritable problème c'est que l'inserm
a sorti une évaluation de l'homéopathie
et l'on dit ça servait à rien bon tu
l'as eu toi personne n'a su parce que
cette communication a été faite de
manière un petit peu à voilà visible en
l existence et il ya un rapport une
série sur le bo qui dit rien voilà donc
on est très content mais y'a pas grand
chose et on a des tas de trucs là dessus
enfin je sais pas s'ils l'ont fait pour
l'homme et au vin vieux doute maintenant
chez qui l'on fait pour l'acupuncture je
sais qu'ils ont fait pour la
mésothérapie pour lomé au je pense que
c'est surtout les rapports oraux plein
qui sont sortis et l'académie de
médecine ça change rien ils ont produit
un savoir il ya des études qui ont été
menées il ya des méta analyse qui existe
nous on est juste là pour en faire écho
et on pourra faire des fusions et pour
dire aux gens le fait scientifique et là
il faut qu'ils se traduisent en fait
politique c'est à dire que tu dis que tu
dis que je ne sais pas ce médicament ne
fonctionne pas donc il doit y avoir une
action politique qui fait que ce
médicament est retiré du marché
c'est compliqué tu vois mais dans l'idée
c'est ça c'est de dire le fait
scientifique près vous et c'est c'est
dans les faits dans dans le truc ça
paraît évident comme ça ça ne l'est pas
du tout parce que il ya un attachement
des gens à l'homéopathie parce que
politiquement aller défoncer
l'homéopathie c'est se braquer toute une
population qui est très adeptes qui est
en général ce sp plus enseignants tout
ça et c'est compliqué d'aller à ce
marbre et avec ces gens là parce que
c'est des gens qui votent aussi dans le
genre ça fait partie des objectifs de
l'inserm dehors communiqué leur promo de
recherche américain woods mais aidé dans
sa maison mais l'objectif l'objectif de
l'inserm louis qu'ils ne supportent je
doute pas une seconde qu'ils ne
supportent
mais le véritable problème c'est que
l'inserm va pas prendre position il va
pas aller exploser la ministre de la
santé ou la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur en lui disant oh on fait de la
merde là avec ça c'est pas leur rôle
leur rôle c'est de produire du savoir
scientifique de rester institutionnel
c'est à dire de rester quand même neutre
et de pas avoir une influence sur le sur
le volet politique et ça c'est le rôle
qu'on essaie de prendre au moins en
médecine ont aumoins médecine et la
promotion des sciences fait partie de
leur mission
oui oui oui non mais évidemment que ça
fait partie de leur de leur mission mais
est ce que tu vois très sincèrement le
cnrs ou l'inserm demandé à la suite
d'une étude qu'ils ont commandée par
exemple qui dit que l'alimentation je
sais pas que l'alimentation en légumes
c'est vachement cool et que qu'ici on
mange plus de légumes et si on mange
plus en régime méditerranéen
ça va mieux est ce que tu vois l'inserm
se lever et 10 rebonds à partir de
maintenant on demande que la ministre
fasse en sorte que les légumes soit deux
fois moins cher
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas le faire enfin
le faire publiquement jeudi sa maison tu
vois tu dis tu vois tu vois c'est
loading csssae ce lobbying
il n'est pas fait il n'existe pas c'est
à dire que les avis qu'ils émettent
ok effectivement ils ont du poids parce
que c'est une institution reconnue parce
que c'est une institution nationale
parce que c'est quelque chose
voilà c'est super ce qu'ils font mais le
portage politique c'est à dire le fait
que des scientifiques se positionne et
disent écoutez il ya un fait
scientifique est établi faisons en
fonction de ce fait scientifique pour
essayer de poser de poser des décisions
politiques parce que ce qui existe en
fait ces différents lobbys
pharmaceutiques ou autres qui sont ils
ont de la thune et tout ça c'est très
bien ils font leurs bizet il ça se passe
bien mais ya pas de lobby scientifiques
y a pas un gros groupe de scientifiques
de mecs un peu
vénère tu vois qui arrivent et qui
disent eh bien nous nous on n'est pas
contents nous ça ça ne va pas nous ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça nous on est en
difficulté nous on a besoin qu'ils et
elles mesures qui sont mises en place et
qui s'appuie exclusivement sur le fait
scientifique pour porter une politique
c'est ça qui est un peu nouveau c'est à
dire que ont fait le lobbying
scientifique parce que le lobbying de
l'antiscience il existe il est financé
des mecs qui au travers de d'émissions
de télé se présente comme une
alternative sympathique un suivi
gynécologique
il y en a plein c'est insupportable ces
gens là existent ces gens là bas ils ont
de la thune à gagner au travers de ça
donc ils se battent pour ça nous en tant
que scientifique comme n'y a pas
beaucoup de maya ce faire sur le fait
que les gens mangent plus de légumes de
notre côté mais tout le monde s'en
mordent quoi fin donc voilà sur
l'homéopathie on n'avait rien à gagner
rien du
gagne 0 pilote c'est ok donc c'est pas
c'est pas les actions que tu vas voir
poindre le plus facilement parce que
meilhat on n'y gagne rien quoi il n'ya
rien personne et financé on fait tout ça
sur notre temps libre
donc oui il faudrait qu'ils une
institution qui existe je sais pas fink
temps où quelque chose d'un petit peu
puissant qui au moins une puissance je
suis pas médiatique ou une existence je
sais pas comment te dire un pouvoir de
lobbying quelconque pour pouvoir porter
ces idées là pour pouvoir dire voilà et
moi je souhaiterais que sur le plan
scientifique
ce soit quelque chose de plus généralisé
c'est à dire que lier en groupement de
scientifiques militants politisés entre
guillemets c'est à dire qu'ils ont une
action sur le champ politique qui disent
merde le climato-scepticisme c'est
inadmissible on demande à ce que il ya
des lois pour éviter des discours qui
sont complètement débile comme ça on en
a ras le cul qu' il ya des anti vaccins
qu'ils aient pignon sur rue donc il
faudrait faire quelque chose on en a ras
le cul que de devoir passer notre temps
à dire que la terre n'est pas plate
parce que ça fait chier quoi on en a
marre de devoir se défendre parce qu'il
ya des reportages tous les jours qu'ils
sortent qui sont d'une débilité
confondante et qui sont anti
scientifique
c'est vraiment ça le fond de la démarche
c'est à dire de dire voilà on aimerait
peser sur la diffusion des contenus on
aimerait peser sur les décisions
politiques on aimerait que mais se fait
scientifique et une existence et que ce
soit pas cantonné à je sais pas une
opinion de gauche où nos clients de
droite c'est voilà c'est le projet après
cette présence messieurs je pense pas
qu'avec fait mais des nos quatre bouts
de ficelle et et notre pas d'argent on
arrive à faire quelque chose qui soit
véritablement à la hauteur de ce que
mériteraient la production scientifique
mais ça donne une idée de ce qui est
possible de faire
on était une centaine
on a quand même bouger un petit peu à un
commerce très installé et une pseudo
médecine qui avait pignon sur rue ce
n'est pas rien je pense que c'est pas
rien c'est pas fait je pense pas que
l'homéopathie va partir en désuétude à
l'an prochain quoi je pense que ça va
prendre du temps et beaucoup de temps
d'éducation des populations
beaucoup de décisions politiques
beaucoup de choses comme ça que il n'y a
rien qui ait véritablement finie mais je
pense que on a besoin d'exister sur ce
champ politique et que si on n'existe
pas sur ce champ politique
c'est toujours d'autres mecs qui
prennent la place tu l'as vu s'il n'y a
personne n'y a aucun euro a aucun
neurologue en neurologue qui s'exprime
correctement sur le plan public tu voit
l'émergence de deux mecs qui font de la
neuro à de la neuro manipulation un peu
chelou là qui s'habille en crimée avec
des faux diplômes et qui occupe cet
espace médiatique parce que les gens
sont curieux de ça et que en fait ce
qu'on leur donne à manger mais c'est une
espèce de de sciences complètement
corrompu parce que c'est une science qui
est beaucoup plus lisible
donc voilà ce que tu vas le futur
comment est ce que je vois le futur le
fait que m c'est une excellente question
je pense que on aurait on aurait
beaucoup d'intérêt à travailler avec la
miviludes ont avec les instituts contre
les dérives sectaires parce qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui se
développe à ce niveau là c'est pas
véritablement des sectes à proprement
parler mais il ya un niveau d'emprise
mentale à des pseudo médecine qui est
assez fort c'est un fort un cours en
entrée en prix mais parce que c'est des
gens qui sont vulnérables
donc je pense qu'on a du travail à faire
de ce côté là je pense qu'on a beaucoup
de lobbying
c'est à dire au niveau des députés a
développé c'est à dire de pouvoir
interagir avec les forces politiques en
présence avec les décideurs pour pouvoir
porter un petit peu le messager qui est
pas que les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
ou
les groupes d'intérêts qui soit
résistant il faudrait que mène notre
voie elle existe un petit peu au travers
de tout ça je pense que ça ce serait
souhaitable je pense que ça ferait du
bien un peu à tout le monde
il ya il ya beaucoup de choses entre rim
et à ce niveau là c'est à dire il faut
utiliser les mêmes armes que nos ennemis
pour faire pour arriver à diffuser le
savoir scientifique
c'est à dire la communication sur les
réseaux sociaux et pas de raison pour
que y'a que les groupes anti vaccins qui
pullulent sur un sur facebook
il y à la communication sur youtube il
n'y a pas de raison qu'il y ait que dès
que des mecs affreux qui vendait des
cocottes minutes quantique qui existe
sur youtube et sur l'ensemble du champ
politique d du chan décisionnel
on doit utiliser leurs armes pour se
défendre contre eux mais tout simplement
parce qu'il ya des choses que tu veux
que vous avez fait est que je pense que
vous pourriez faire faire mieux que les
endroits où vous pourriez progresser
enfin progresser oui je te rappelle
qu'on est juste un groupe d'une centaine
de hippies qui sont regroupés parce
qu'on a pris une volée de plainte
donc ouais ouais je pense qu'il ya de la
marge pour pour des progrès mais c'est
difficile parce que et avec un groupe de
bénévoles si tu veux donc les mecs font
ça sur leur temps libre
d'un pas d'argent donc je peux pas
financer quelqu'un pour créer du savoir
scientifique créer de l'interaction tous
à temps plein donc je suis un peu
tributaire des volonté de tout un chacun
et c'est comme ça c'est peut-être plus
un mais bon c'est quand même nettement
moins efficace quoi donc
donc voilà donc peut-être avoir des gens
qui se consacre à temps plein à la cause
qu'ils arrivent à se faire rémunérer
vis-à-vis de tout ça ça peut être en
plus d'avoir plus de contacts avec les
associations de patients parce que les
premiers qui se font à qui son unique
essai eu de toute façon parce que nous
les médecins à la rigueur on connaît pas
le chômage on connaît pas la crise
il est d'ailleurs j'ai eu beaucoup de
réponses à tout ça
beaucoup de réponses de certains
décideurs qui m'ont dit mais pourquoi
vous êtes allé faire ça sans déconner
vous avez un personnes à recruter il n'y
a rien à gagner je dis non mais c'est
pas ça c'est juste alors à dix mais de
toute façon ça va rien changer les
consultations seront toujours tout plein
et tout ça oui mais on aura peut-être
il ya eu un rapport qui a changé moi
j'étais contente parce que j'ai eu
plusieurs médecins qui m'ont dit baye
mais petite madame l'aqim exige l
homéopathie maintenant sont venus me
poser des questions et l on venus
questionner leurs rapports parce
qu'elles ont entendu un discours un peu
contradictoires ça j'aime beaucoup de me
dire que madame michu qui était
convaincu pendant vingt ans que
l'homéopathie soigner la grippe tout
d'un coup elle a entendu des trucs à la
radio qui on peut ébranler ses
certitudes et elle est venue poser la
question à son médecin et son médecin il
était bien content de pas avoir à
refaire ce renouvellement d'ordonnancé
machin est de pouvoir discuter un petit
peu du fonds est de pouvoir peut-être
aidé la dame sur le véritable problème
qu'elle a c'est à dire le recours
incessant médicaments et tout ça donc ça
c'était positif mais c'est toujours
compliqué si tu veux de dire on est sur
une structure associative et tout le
monde participe à sa petite échelle et
en même temps de dire il faudrait que ça
se professionnalise avec les billets que
ça peut bien que ça peut inclure c'est à
dire que est ce qu'on aura toujours la
même objectivité avec des gens qui sont
financés est ce qu'on aura toujours le
même rapport un petit peu sain avec les
gens c'est à dire que là les jambes et
en fait on fait ce qu'on peut quoi on
communique mais les gens voient bien
qu'il n'y a pas d'arrière pensée
derrière quoi ont du moins j'espère donc
voilà donc c'est toujours un petit peu a
questionné donc ouais il faudrait qu'ils
aient plus d'argent pour permettre que
quelqu'un fasse à temps plein ce qui
sera pas mon cas parce que maire je
ferais jamais ça à temps plein donc pour
la suite ce serait pas mal et que l'on
puisse
travailler peut-être sur d'autres votre
chemin parce que je pense que la
désinformation
c'est un problème pas seulement médical
mais scientifique de manière générale et
je trouve tout se sait tout aussi grave
de décrédibiliser un domaine comme
l'astrophysique ou l'astronomie que de
le faire sur le plan sur le plan médical
parce que ça dénote d'un état d'esprit
parce que c'est les mêmes personnes en
fait ces mêmes personnes qui croient aux
théories du complot sur la lune donc que
sur l'homéopathie et tout ça quoi ces
gens qui sont inféodés qui sont
persuadés que quelque part quelqu'un
essaie de leur faire du mal en montant
un complot dans leur dos ou quoi et
voilà et c'est ce raisonnement là ont
trimé qui m'apparaît dangereux de
diffuser quoi et c'est un une logique
une réflexion qui est très présente
entre limite dans les milieux d'extrême
gauche et d'extreme droite
d'un côté parce qu'il ya un rejet de des
grosses entreprises et tout ça de
l'autre parce qu'il ya un rejet global
des élites et des gens qui ont un niveau
universitaire parce que c'est dangereux
donc des deux côtés c'est compliqué et
des deux côtés je pense qu'il ya des
solutions à proposer quoi et que de
toute façon il faut qu'on travaille à
communiquer mieux mieux différemment à
de proposer quelque chose qui soit
acceptable quoi voilà donc c'est dans la
tête apparaît aussi pas mal de des
réseaux sociaux parce que j'imagine que
beaucoup de ce mouvement grossissement
via les réseaux sociaux
ouais du coup elle est câline youtube
qui a annoncé récemment qu'il voulait
modifier un peu l'algorithme pour qu'ils
arrêtent de de recommander des vidéos
conspirationnistes tu penses que je
pense l'algorithme de youtube est fait
de telle manière qu'ils favorisent
aujourd'hui la diffusion de contenus
viraux c'est à dire de contenus qui sont
choquants facilement accessible et qui
suscite une réaction
de manière générale c'est comme ça que
fonctionne l'algorithme à 2 de facebook
de twitter etc y mettre en avant ce qui
suscite une réaction donc l'algorithme
de youtube en lui-même il est biaisé
c'est à dire qu'en lui-même y portent
les germes de sa c'est à dire que à une
conférence d'un scientifique calé sur un
sujet va toujours avoir moins d'audience
que un contenu complotistes donc le fait
que youtube et c'est de modifier son
algorithme pour - les mettre en avant
je trouve ça positif c'est à dire qu' on
essaie de retrouver un petit peu de
normalité au travers de ce réseau est
d'éviter entre lee mais que le discours
complotistes ou la désinformation
utilisent les failles de ceci parce que
lorsque vous travestissez une
information vous utilisez toujours les
billets pour permettre sa diffusion le
plus possible et en général un intitulé
choquant une miniature racoleuse et tout
ça vous emparer c'est pas entre
guillemets tut embarrasse pas du tout de
la véracité scientifique de la
parcimonie du fait de mettre des nuances
tout ça que t'en fous tu balances tu
balances plein de peau tu fais peur
tuera colle avec un enfant qui pleure et
tu racontes plein de conneries tu t'en
fous de toute façon ton objectif c'est
pas d'avoir une information fiable c'est
d'appuyer ton a priori pour faire en
sorte que ce soit diffuser le plus
possible donc à partir du moment où les
mecs ont réussi à hacker le système pour
faire en sorte d'être mis en avant nous
on doit avoir des mesures des contre
mesures
voire à quai à notre tour fin utiliser
le système de notre côté pour pouvoir
tout ça donc qu'ils émettent moins en
avant c'est bien mais ce contenu existe
de toute façon il va se diffuser et
l'argument de la censure genre youtube
et ses de m'étendre parce que je dis la
vérité qui dérange est un argument qui
est éculé qui est utilisé très
fréquemment par un nos collègues
complotistes donc ça c'est pas mal mais
sans un minimum de pédagogie sans un
minimum de réflexion vis-à-vis de tout
ça sans questionner notre rapport à la
consommation des contenus pour les
viewer notamment c'est quelque chose qui
a aucun intérêt c'est à dire que si a
pas de minimum de pédagogie de
discussion de capacité à triel contenu
c'est c'est complètement con quoi ces
voix là il faut que l'on apprenne ont je
pense aux plus jeunes et même moins
jeunes 1 comment on consomme sur les
réseaux sociaux comment est ce que on
excepte l'information avant on en avait
davantage d'avoir une télé qui était à
peu près normes et est en gros les gens
avaient une confiance en la télé parce
qu'il y avait une espèce d'autorité qui
régulait tout ça le véritable problème
des réseaux sociaux et de youtube en
soit c'est que y'a pas cette régulation
c'est à dire juste en robot et la
quantité d'informations la masse
d'informations qui est donnée peut pas
être régulée sur un plan humain c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya pas quelqu'un qui va des
dirigé l'édition qui va dire ben bella
il faudrait avoir un contenu un petit
peu plus scientifique et le fait qu'il y
ait cette diffusion qui unit père
disponibilité des contenus fait que
c'est convenu mais ils diffusent quand
même beaucoup plus facilement et les
gens ont gardé ce réflexe télé c'est à
dire si c'est diffusé si quelqu'un le
met sur une vidéo où si je peux y
accéder c'est que c'est vrai et moi j'ai
le problème avec arte c'est à dire que
les gens viennent me voir et ils me
disent mais je les ai vus sur arte arte
c'est quand même plus les titres que
vous qui est cardiologue que de fumer à
carreaux là on en a rien à [ __ ] on lui
fasse à la télé quand même
lui pète la classe il passe à la télé
donc s'ils passent à la télé c'est qu'il
est dit et on a beaucoup ça en fait
et les gens ont la même réflexion
vis-à-vis de youtube il est sur youtube
il a x 1000 abonnés 1 est la classe c
bien voilà et c'est comme ça que vous
avez dû convenu kaka qui a 5 millions
d'abonnés et on dit abc à 5 millions de
gens qui croient ça veut dire que c'est
bien et du coup c'est de la merde et
c'est compliqué et il faut qu'on
apprenne au genre à questionner notre
rapport à ces contenus
on ne peut pas et on n'aurait pas dû
même avec la télé prendre les contenus
qui sont disponibles comme argent
comptant sans critique sans réflexion
derrière il y a moins il faut que les
gens soient capables de lire ça et ce
que fait christophe michel alik hygiène
mentale sur l'éducation des jeunes tout
ça sur le questionnement tout ça de
notre rapport à l'information je pense
que c'est vers ça qu'il va falloir aller
je pense que en éducation nationale et
de manière générale il faudrait qu'on
ait une éducation basique à la médecine
à la manière de créer du savoir
scientifique à la à comment est ce qu'on
fait et comment est-ce qu'on critique
une information qui est donnée à une
éducation fait que nous de manière
générale parce que c'est quelque chose
qui est en veille notre schéma de pensée
et c'est quelque chose qui va favoriser
entre guillemets des individus mal
intentionnés pour manipuler les gens et
voilà donc il faut qu'il existe une
alternative à ces contenus qui sont
malveillants il faut qu'ils soient que
les contenus malveillants sont moins mis
en avant par youtube mais là encore
marqué de manière jeu et dès que la
faille sera trouvée de toute façon elle
sera comblé donc c'est un pansement sur
une jambe de bois
mais il faut travailler à la source
c'est-à-dire que la diffusion d'un
contenu comme ça ce soit entre
guillemets réprouvé c'est à dire que ce
soit je sais pas illégal ou malvenue
quoi c c'est pas normal de diffuser ne
s'est pas de normal ou légitime de
diffuser un contenu qui incite les gens
à ne pas se maxine et ça tue les gens de
ça c'est il ya des gens du haras faute
tu pense qu'il faudrait des mesures
légales contre la diffusion de contenu à
je pense oui je pense que l'impunité
participe très largement au fait que les
gens à créer diffuse du contenu du
contenu comme ça c'est pas normal c'est
pas normal de raconter des trucs qui
peuvent tuer les gens de dire que les
vaccins donne le cancer ça ça tue les
gens c'est à dire que quand vous avez
quelqu'un qui est inféodée à ce genre de
théorie est que ça puisse diffuser
vous avez des gamins qui vont pas être
vaccinés contre la rougeole et qui vont
potentiellement tombé malade de nourrir
ce n'est pas acceptable moi je parle sur
un plan santé parce que c'est le plan
qui me concerne évidemment parce qu'il
ya un risque de dérive ya un risque
d'emprise mentale qui est fort et qui
met les gens en difficulté et de manière
générale
l'emprise mentale que l'on va avoir tué
et avait trouvé l'épisode laquelle fasse
trop nos geeks et tous les compères là
sur les crop circle l'utilisation des
crop circle par des charlatans pour
essayer d'avoir une emprise mentale sur
eux et pour leur faire refuser certaines
attitudes de santé tout ça c'est quelque
chose que je trouve extrêmement
problématique le complotisme de manière
générale et d'espèces de mysticisme
ambiant favorise ce genre de choses et
ce n'est pas acceptable et donner une
porte d'entrée à ces gens là pour faire
du charlatanisme pour faire des
médecines alternatives et problématiques
donc oui qu'il y ait un arsenal légal
pour taper sur les créateurs de contenu
qui sont volontairement
malveillants dangereux etc oui après
selon quelles modalités c'est toujours
ça qui est compliqué c'est à dire que
l'instrument légal
il doit être utilisé avec parcimonie
c'est à dire tu peux pas si quelqu'un
dit de la merde en toute bonne foi sur
internet tu peux pas lui tomber sur la
gueule il menacé de prendre procès donc
c'est très compliqué je pense qu'il ya
une notion d'intentionnalité je pense
que il y à l'emprise mentale qui est
importante c'est pour ça que le travail
avec l'idée avec les agents des dérives
sectaires est assez important parce que
moi ce qui me révolte c'est de voir des
contenus ou les mecs explique qu'il faut
arrêter tous les médicaments
anticancéreux et se soigner avec des jus
de fruits et qu'ils en profitent pour
vendre des mixeurs à des prêts ce légume
à 150 balles ça m'arrive
et ces mecs là le font en toute impunité
à ce qu'on dit mais on respecte la
liberté de choix des patients
et tout ça et je ne pense pas je pense
vraiment pas qu'on respecte leur liberté
de choix quand on dans leur donne ça au
contraire c'est de la désinformation
pure et dure et ces gens là sont
manipulés d'une manière ou d'une autre
donc est-ce que c'est légitime de les
laisser s'exprimer au nom de la liberté
d'expression
quand l'heure leur discours est
potentiellement mortifère j'en suis pas
sûr après comment est-ce qu'on peut agir
là dessus
moi j'ai pas légaliste mais je pense que
wayne impunité est quelque chose qui
joue là dessus et de toute façon de
manière générale l'impunité sur internet
est quelque chose qui a beaucoup joué
pour des comportements particulièrement
des viandes et j'ai pas ce que tu en
penses toi mais tu vois ce qu'il
faudrait faire mais moi je trouve que
c'est révoltant de l'essai de laisser
ces mecs là est de leur dire bon il se
passe rien voilà donc les légiférer sur
ça ça ne paraît pas simple et simplement
bien sûr bien sûr que non mais moi quand
tu vois toutes les conférences du
professeur joyeux qui sont disponibles
sur internet
ça me chagrine ont tu vois enfin ce mec
là raconte les pires conneries sur sur
le métier ils déshonorent la profession
tout ce qui peut et m'a dit qu'elle est
voilée on me dit non mais les docteurs
donc savoir non non ça va pas non c'est
pas normal ce n'est pas normal et ça
doit être combattue et de la même
manière qu'en reportage merdique 1 doit
être combattu que 1,10 une diffusion de
savoir doit être combattue à une
diffusion de savoir erronée doit être
combattue je pense que il ya ce travail
à faire aussi sur sur nos plateformes
après moi mon approche c'est de proposer
un contenu entre guillemets vertueux
pour compenser le contenu nul pour dire
voilà il existe en contenu vertueux
manger en année ça suffit pas
manifestement je viens justement sur
l'éducation
parce que l'éducation le truc qui est
compliqué avec les ducs et payet
plusieurs choses qui sont compliquées
par rapport à l'éducation mais une des
choses qui concluent pas une chose qu'à
ses mises à part par éducation c'est que
c'est souvent dirigée surtout vers les
jeunes et du coup c'est juste les jeunes
sont aujourd'hui les problèmes
enfin ce qui leur est il tellement sont
pas les jeunes qui arrivent et toute une
partie de la population qu'il faudrait
du coup éduquer ces temps il question
nationale a pas trop de deux moins de
les éduquer puis l'autre problème c'est
aussi que l'éducation aux médias c'est
quand ça requiert des gens qui sont
capables de d'enseigner l'éducation
média l'esprit critiqué les méthodes
scientifiques et tout ça est et c'est
difficile de trouver ces gens là je
pense qu'il ya pas mal chez les
enseignants et notamment au niveau
primaire
il ya pas mal de craintes et déjà des
mathématiques et voir des sciences manca
d'être fait d'être heureux d'être
relégué au second plan et que ce soit
pas considérée comme étant prioritaire
bien sûr mais c'est évident que c'est
quelque chose de problématique de faire
tout ça le véritable problème c'est que
ça devient difficile et comme tu l'as
dit effectivement le problème concerne
pas seulement les jeunes je pense même
que les jeunes sont mieux armés à mon
avis vis-à-vis de ces médias parce
qu'ils ont grandi avec
parce qu'ils en connaissent les limites
qui connaît ce machin ils savent ce qui
est bullshit ce qui l'est moins et ils
sont capables d'avoir un petit peu il
considère - le média ou les réseaux
sociaux comme quelque chose de
globalement fiables ils vont avoir
tendance à recouper les infos à chercher
ailleurs à se méfier de certains sites
c'est pas le cas des pas des personnes
les plus âgées
un vieux de 60 ans et il est sur le
réseau social que je sais pas que des
migrants ont envahi tel truc il y croit
parce que c'est diffusé parce que c'est
une information est pour lui une
information est une force et une
information vraie de principe en est je
pense que c'est plus problématique
effectivement chez ces gens qui sont pas
entre guillemets biberonné à c'est à ces
nouveaux médias
c'est plus problématique pour eux de
comprendre entre lee mais qu' ils ont
ils sont critiquables et qu'ils sont à
prendre avec des pincettes je pense
aussi qu'il y avait une diffusion puis
la plus avant de convenu qui était
problématique mais qui était pas entre
guillemets visualiser comme tel c'est
vraiment l'émergence aussi des réseaux
sociaux qui a fait que on s'est beaucoup
dit attendez il ya quand même plein de
conneries quoi quand même
et à mon avis est plein de conneries qui
était dite
les années 60 les années 70 et 80 mais
principalement de la propagande sur le
plan médiatique donc c'est aussi très
bien accueilli y ait cette existence des
réseaux sociaux pour pouvoir discuter de
tous up pouvoir se poser pour pouvoir
analyser sur les données scientifiques
c'est pas quelque chose
enfin ce que je vois par survenir sur
twitter c'est pas quelque chose que les
gens auraient fait spontanément à
l'époque de la télévision mois après
j'ai des jeunes hommes aussi moi je
regardais la télévision je me disais pas
vidéo qu'est ce que ce qui est donc est
ce que ce qui vient dans c'est pas
sorcier c'est bien vrai tout çà non
souhaitée dans c'est pas sorcier c'était
vachement bien est super et même s'il
avait dit une connerie ou deux je me
serais jamais fendu d'une lettre pour
leur dire oh là là ça me paraît un peu
curieux je me serais dit ouais bon
d'accord là donc je pense que ça aussi
apporter cet éveil critique
les réseaux sociaux ont apporté 7 et les
critiques cette compréhension et cette
manière de dire réfléchissons quand même
vis-à-vis des contenus qu'on regarde
mais ça a donné aussi un porte voix à
cette désinformation qui qui est
rampante des qui est très efficace
c'est la désinformation médical qui
responsable du recul de la vaccination
en france majoritairement n'y a rien
d'autre que la désinformation médical
que ces réseaux sociaux et que c'est que
là que la communication au niveau des
médias qui est une petite de la
désinformation à proprement parler qui a
motivé les gens à moins se vacciner
pendant pendant deux ans et qui a mené
au drame qu'on a connu avec ces gens ces
patients qui sont décédés tout ça donc
c'est quelque chose mais qui à notre
rapport aux médias qui est complexe et
je pense mais qu'il faudrait éduquer les
gens plus avant je pense que les
contenus comme ça qui parle d' éduquer
les gens doivent être mis plus en avant
après quelle solution on a vis-à-vis de
la pédagogie il y en a plein il y en a
aucune qui pleinement satisfaisante
je suis même pas sûr que si on faisait
10 heures d'éducation aux médias par
semaine
pour tous les gamins du primaire je suis
même pas sûr que ça les empêche pas ce
que toute façon la désinformation
s'adressent à des publics qui sont
vulnérables
et quand on est vulnérable on n'exerce
pas son esprit critique
c'est des gens qui sont malades des gens
qui ont des enfants malades des femmes
enceintes des femmes avec des enfants en
bas âge ans et voilà c'est ce public là
où des gens qui ont des maladies
chroniques comme je t'ai dit c'est ce
public là qui est ciblé et ce public là
même s'il a eu la meilleure éducation
possible même si il est bien éduqué tout
ça par force
il est très poreux à ce genre de truc et
c'est lui qui va tomber en premier et du
coup l île et que j'aurai plus par
rapport aux algorithmes de
recommandations c'est s'est pas
seulement ne pas recommander les vidéos
conspirationnistes ou anti vaccins mais
également mettre en avant les vidéos
éducatives fin des vidéos de type manque
d'hygiène mentale ou des vidéos ou des
vidéos un peu qu'il fasse réfléchir à la
méthode et qui apprennent aussi de
l'esprit critique vis-à-vis de de
contenus très peu plus problématique
tout à fait mais ça ce sera intéressant
mais ça s'appelle une ligne éditoriale
est à tu sais tu sais bien que sur
youtube la ligne éditoriale c'est pas
oulala éduquons les masses en ligne et
auriel de youtube c'est ouhlala il faut
faire des vues donc que lille est bonne
si tu veux oui moi si tu me demandais ce
que youtube devrait même plus mettre en
avant nos vidéos oui oui clairement mais
est-ce que youtube va le faire n'ont
clairement pas clairement pas non c'est
pas un contenu qui est un vendeur c'est
ça s'adresse à un public qui est ciblé
il faut avoir un niveau entre rim et
scientifique minimale pour peut-être
pour y accéder c'est ce que je me dis et
je pense que c'est un tort mais bon il
faut quand même que les gens soient un
minimum intéressé par le truc sinon ils
peuvent être rapidement perdu même avec
des vidéos comme moi qui sont quand même
ciblé grand public je sais que en
dessous du niveau lycée c'est compliqué
quoi
donc je me dis que oui ce serait
vachement bien que non contenue ce plus
mis en avant que les contenus
complotistes soit mis à l'amande même
qu'il soit viré tu vois ce serait
vachement bien mais c'est pas dans la
ligne de youtube et on est sur youtube
pour une raison très simple c'est pas
parce que c'est une plate forme ultra
cool et ultra-léger tu vois on est sur
youtube parce que c'est la plateforme
qui est la plus visitée
lorsque c'est celle qui a le plus de
trafic on pourrait les sur des
plateformes alternatives mes couilles
tout ça c'est vachement bien mais c'est
pas les plates formes qui sont avisés
par les jeunes c'est pas les plateformes
où les gens vont aller spontanément on
peut aller sur des plates formes
alternatives
oui mais voilà j'aurai pas de genre
d'homme qui vont tomber sur ma vidéo et
qui vont me dire a couru série à
c'est aussi ça qui nous manque donc donc
et youtube et sur son modèle économique
que allah publicitaire que la vue créer
machin donc il faudrait revoir entre
guillemets le modèle économique qui mène
youtube a favorisé plusieurs comptes
tels contenus plutôt que d'autres c'est
à dire que peut-être que sortir du
modèle publicitaire à stricto sensu et
partir sur autre chose mais est ce que
c'est possible est ce que dans le monde
dans lequel on est assez c'est jouable
je ne sais pas je sais pas mais tant
qu'on se rassure modèle publicitaire qui
rémunérera à la vue c'est à dire au
nombre de pubs qui seront visualisées
mais les contenus à lacombe
ils seront quand même beaucoup plus
visualiser que les contenus à qui son
travail et réfléchie ou qui tendent un
peu les neurones ou alors il faut qu'on
se remette gravement en question pour
essayer de créer du contenu qu'ils
soient ultra sexy qui donne ultra envie
et que et qui piègent un petit peu le
spectateur et qu'ils le fassent
réfléchir malgré lui quoi les vaches je
pense qui fâchent et youtube
il ya quand même pas mal de gens qui
sont éduqués qui aiment les sciences et
tout ça il ya beaucoup d'ingénieurs de
chercheurs
et qui je pense qu'ils veulent que le
mans bien faire ces gens là après sa
lecture des actionnaires et tous acquis
un peu compliqué mais si s'il ya un peu
de pression comme ça si on peut aussi
faire du lobbying auprès de ces
entreprises je pense à mais je suis
d'accord à 100% c'est je pense oui je
pense mais c'est de toute façon on est
dans une société où la logique
économique près vous et c'est aussi pour
ça que tu as entre guillemets la
création de séchelles d'infotainment tu
sais tout ce qui est combiné à tout ça
ces chaînes d'info telle demande en fait
ce sont des chaînes qui sont éminemment
publicitaire c'est à dire qu'ils sont
financés par des aides et des acteurs
privés dans coca-cola tous à machin pour
créer de l'information qui va peser
c'est à dire l'information qui va être
ultra sexy et de la mélanger un peu
insidieusement avec de la publicité
c'est à dire de temps en temps tu vas
voir sur un succès sur ces schémas là tu
vas voir une pub pour kfc qui sera pas
dit qe comme étant de la pub mais c'est
quand même de la pub et cette espèce de
limites floues entre ce qui relève de la
publicité et du partenariat tout ça
c'est quelque chose qui a beaucoup
instauré youtube avec les partenariats
que tu avais avec les très très gros
youtuber n'était pas indiquée comme
partenaire mais qui en sont un peu mais
que quand même pas trop mais voilà et de
fait de concourir à flouter les limites
entre ce qui est de la publicité c'est à
dire du contenu rémunérés et ce qui est
le contenu loyal du mec qui va présenter
c'est quelque chose qui rentre un peu
aussi dans ce domaine là est temps que
tu auras une logique économique
publicitaire c'est à dire qu'en tant que
là tu ne rentreras au travers de gens
qui font de la pub mails publicitaires
va avoir un droit de regard sur ce que
tu publies c'est à dire que voilà si tu
publies re dans ta vidéo des trucs
vachement intéressant sur le 11
septembre mais que de ton publicitaires
et dit non le 11 septembre ça fait chier
la vidéo elle sera moins mises en avant
et donc oui effectivement que il ya des
ingénieurs sur youtube qui veulent faire
le bien qu'on a envie d'avoir une plate
forme qui soit
vertueuse qui soit positive qu' il y ait
des gens comme comme les eaux par
exemple qui participent à des trucs sur
youtube qui sont rémunérés et qui sont
valorisés parce que leur contenu est
extrêmement vertueux et parce que ce que
ça met en avant sur sur leur plateforme
c'est quand même très positif c'est
hubert cool d'avoir un leo sur la plate
forme parce que c'est super bien tu vois
si le mec et coup le mec fait de la
science il fait pas des profs des bills
fait pas des trucs dégueulasses y fait
pas du contenu poubelle donc c'est
vachement bien d'avoir ce mec là mais
mais voilà c'est ce sera pas aussi mis
en avant qu'un mec qui va faire cinq
millions de vues ou que qu'un clip ou
que machin parce que c'est
voilà c'est ça fais pas du chiffre ça ça
fait pas du lift on est et c'est de plus
en plus compliquées et tu vois que l'on
compte tenu de change évolue parce que
le contente heidi devient de plus en
plus agressive donc tu peux pas mettre
n'importe quelle musique tu peux pas
mettre n'importe à n'importe quelle
image tu te fais clem dès que dès que tu
peux aider que tu te fais clem beta
vidéo elle est moins mise en avant de
toute façon donc tu es obligé de faire
du contenu soit une phrase sobre pour
éviter justement d'être clé mais du coup
que ta vidéo soit moins vu ou alors il
faut que tu fasses du contenu qu'ils
soient ultra référencé ultra ultra
punchy pour essayer d'être d'être mis en
avant c'est un peu c'est un peu
compliqué nos contenus de toute façon on
évolue tu fais pas le même contenu en
fonction de la plateforme qui te diffuse
de toute façon parce que tu sais que tu
vas voir tel truc qui va l'emmerder tu
sais que tu vas voir tel truc qui va te
faire chier tu sais que si tu vas parler
de telles choses ça va moins bien se
passer
donc voilà et cette logique économique
influe directement sur la qualité sur ce
qu on se complaît dans le contenu puis
donc c'est on ne peut pas on peut pas
sortir de cette logique là de toute
façon et oui ce serait cool mais est ce
que ce serait faisable
je sais pas mais je pense si on se place
à laisser la place deux de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
qu'on va améliorer la santé mondiale
il semble que petit à petit à se changer
ces algues oreilles de recommandations
et vous devient vivant une priorité ah
oui oui oui mais de toute façon dans les
dents les cibles de l'om sdd plus grand
danger pour la santé je crois que le
discours anti vaccinable discours anti
science notre sixième ou cinquième tu
vois ça veut quand même dire que c'est
quand même pas anodin du tout après on
agit sur des logiques économiques après
c'est exactement ce qu'on dit vis-à-vis
de l'écologie et tout ça il y a
tellement du gros pognon derrière
tellement de machins et on est si petit
nous que des fois on se demande à quoi
bon quoi à quoi bon donc mais il
faudrait qu'on le fasse il faudrait
qu'on ait une attitude beaucoup plus
militante mais il faudrait aussi qu'on
ait des moyens de pression envers
youtube ans et aujourd'hui je sais pas
quels moyens de pression tu as an vers
youtube mais moi je peux leur envoyer un
mail et puis ils me disent
dommage pour toi bisous quoi et puis
c'est tout donc on voit l'enjeu
donc après là il ya eu alors article 13
là qui veut faire en sorte que leurs
contenus soient un peu plus driver
peut-être que ça va nous donner
peut-être une assise je sais pas mais
moi je me dis que si on veut bouger sur
les gars fin et tout ça il faut
peut-être travailler au corps comme je
te l'aï dit sur le plan politique mais
pour faire passer nos idées à ce moment
là tu vois vers le parlement européen ou
des choses comme ça mais pour ça il faut
qu'on ait des scientifiques des
vulgarisateurs qui seront peints minimum
et qui fasse ce travail la france un
truc qui pourra aider par exemple c'est
6 de plus en plus de gens se mettent
d'accord sur le fait que les algorithmes
une recommandation doivent recommander
les vidéos éducatif je pense qu on est
encore très loin d'eux
de ça et tant qu'il n'y a pas une
opinion important qu'ils émergent qui va
dans cette direction enfin c'est normal
que youtube ne prennent pas en
considération même le ms ou n'importe
qui que oui mais parce que il n'ya pas
vraiment d'instances représentatives
entre limay des vidéastes parce que
c'est un travail qui est très
individuelle comme tu le sais on aime
beaucoup beaucoup chez nous beaucoup
tout seul et on s'est pas constitué en
syndicat ou alors les tentatives qui ont
eu lieu bah ouais c'est intéressant mais
c'est pas non plus extrêmement puissante
donc je pense je pense vrai que si on
doit avoir une influence ce sera au
travers de nos créateurs de contenu mais
nos créateurs de contenu ils ont aussi
peur d'être censuré par la plateforme de
diffusion
c'est à dire que s'il commence à faire
un peu les bars mot est un peu expliqué
qu' il aimerait bien que youtube soit
comme ça on peut leur fermer leur gueule
vite fait et je serais quand même c'est
quand même leur outil de travail et donc
ils n'ont pas non plus le très envie et
je pense que beaucoup font un peu leur
beurre de suez ont pas envie de plus
quoi donc ya pas voilà il ya il ya un
petit peu tout ça et oui les créateurs
de contenus devraient se mobiliser parce
que c'est eux qui font le youtube qu'on
aime et c'est eux qui vont pouvoir
valoriser le youtube qu'on aime
après peut-être pas que les fans lors de
contenu c'est peut-être les
consommateurs de ces contenus et là ça
fait beaucoup plus de gens serre certes
oui certes oui effectivement mais quand
je dis les créateurs de contenu si tu as
un créateur de conclure c'est à tous les
créateurs de contenu tout d'un coup qui
arrivent et qui disent bon on en a ras
le cul et l'algorithme l'algorithme
france c'est vraiment de la daube et il
faudrait que on valorise plus tel ou tel
type de contenu voilà mais c'est un peu
ce que j'ai à chacune de mes conférences
traitant ce moment mais voilà est-ce que
est ce que notre lobby il est
suffisamment fort est ce que on pèse
quoi que ce soit face à un squeeze ou
ainsi priant que je je sais pas et c'est
eux qui pèse dans les aime parce qu'ils
sont très importants parce qu'ils ont
une masse d'abonnés qui est qui est
critiqué parce qu'ils ont une voix quoi
donc
donc oui on peut exister oui on a
certains qui ont 1,1 million d'abonnés
c'est cool mais on est on est petit coin
donc si on voulait vraiment pesé sur la
plateforme il faudrait qu'il ya un
engouement massif de la population vers
les vidéos concret mais pour créer un
engouement massif vers les vidéos
concret il faut créer cet engouement et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on devienne
sexy quoi c'est c'est un peu c'est un
peu ce que j ai moi j'ai du mal à être
sexy parce que j'ai déjà j'ai du mal à
écrire en ce moment donc j'écris plus
rien donc je vois là donc c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué mais je pense
que oui on a on a ce rôle on a ce rôle
dé diffusion du savoir et je pense qu'on
a cette mission aussi de faire du
lobbying pour faire en sorte que notre
contenu soit mis en valeur et qu'ils
soient a recommandé après qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire vis-à-vis d'une
multinationale qui est même pas dans
notre pays à part agir au niveau du
parlement européen à part agir au niveau
du législateur c'est à dire du député
pour faire en sorte que voilà après pas
le problème dont il existe des lentilles
vaccination ou des news en général c'est
un prix mondial dans le problème il est
mondial c'est clair mais quand tu vois
par exemple que les écologistes ont sur
une tête une tête de liste sur leur
programme européen qui est ouvertement
anti vaccins qui a soutenu à la
diffusion des films de wakefield qui va
me pires escrocs sur la vaccination qui
existe ce voilà c'est pour ça que je te
dis qu'il faut qu'on existe sur un plan
politique parce que tant qu' on n'existe
pas c'est jean-jacques capitalise là
dessus mais que à la fin mais le
discours complotistes est un peu anti
vaccins ils savent que ça vaut 20 % dans
les sondages et ils se disent que même
s'ils sont sur ce créneau là et ça leur